[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle séance de questions
d'actualité au sénat pendant l'épidémie
de coronavirus en plus des auditions les
sénateurs continue à interroger le
gouvernement une fois par semaine dans
l'hémicycle sur sa gestion de la crise
et sur les conséquences économiques et
sociales de cette situation mais aussi
sur le dé confinement qui débute le 11
mai
la séance commence dans quelques minutes
à 15 heures dans des conditions qui
respectent les consignes sanitaires je
suis avec le style vie robert bonjour je
vous êtes sénatrice socialiste d'ille et
vilaine vice présidente de la commission
de la culture
vous allez poser une question au
gouvernement tout à l'heure justement
sur la situation de la culture qui vous
inquiète
absolument c'est un secteur qui est
comme beaucoup d'autres secteurs
d'activité mais particulièrement touchés
d'autant que si vous vous souvenez les
interdictions de rassemblements de 5000
personnes ont été déjà mises en oeuvre
dès le 1er mars
beaucoup de salles ensuite quel qu'il
soit les théâtres les cinémas ont fermé
et la grande interrogation c'est pour
tout le monde quand vont-ils ouvrir et
je crois que cette incertitude pèse
encore plus au delà de la fragilité du
secteur sur bien la question de la
visibilité des perspectives à donner aux
acteurs bien sûr pour ce secteur c'est
plus compliqué que pour d'autres comme
par exemple pour les restaurants ou pour
les bars vous pour vous quand est-ce
qu'ils doivent rouvrir
écoutez jeu là c'est une question qui
n'appelle pas pour ma part de réponse
lorsque ta dernière qu'ils n'obtiendront
pas tenir et la date et les modalités de
sortie de confinement nous de l'économie
ne les connaissons pas donc la question
sanitaire primes et on sait très bien
que se retrouver dans une salle de
spectacle ou dans un cinéma très peu de
temps après le 11 mai va être absolument
impossible en revanche je crois qu'il
faut que les acteurs culturels et de la
visibilité
ils attendent des règles ils attendaient
protocole très précis
un peu comme l'école voilà quoi quoi
faire lorsqu'on est dans une salle de
théâtre de tant de personnes
il ya confondre examiné on pourrait
imaginer comme dans
hémicycle faire des spectacles pour
alors une personne une jauge vraiment
réduit quand je demande de la visibilité
c'est absolument ses réponses là qui
sont attendus en fonction de la question
sanitaire bien sûr je crois qu'il faut
projeter les acteurs culturels pas
seulement dans l'actualité d'aujourd'hui
mais surtout pour demain parce que je
vais le dire tout à l'heure ils
construisent leur programmation et les
théâtres les cinémas et et surtout les
wheeler a tancé le moment où on
présentera de subventions on va dire
vous avez les grands festivals qui sont
annulés les petits festivals mais je ne
sais pas ce que c'est qu'un petit
festival se pose beaucoup de questions
vous avez vraiment une situation
extrêmement à la fois dramatique mais
aussi je dirais anxiogène du secteur
culturel c'est un secteur qui est
fragile qu'il ya des particularités qui
est vraiment très vaste parce que ça va
du patrimoine au spectacle vivant en
passant par les arts plastiques et
l'audiovisuel vous le savez ça ne répond
à des modèles économiques très divers
donc vraiment il faut avoir une
perspective et il faut anticiper
je crois que ce sera le credo que je je
tiendrai tout au long de ces semaines et
c'est moi qui arrive avec le
gouvernement vous défendent également un
fonds d'urgence pour la culture pour
vous de quel montant doit être doté quel
doit être son principe ans alors je
pense que il y a déjà eu un certain
nombre de mesures qui ont été qui
s'applique au secteur culturel au fonds
de solidarité
l'activité partielle et ça c'est
vraiment très important
par contre on sait très bien que la
question des charges structure se pose
la question des recettes et notamment de
la billetterie ce qu'on apporte plus
doux la fragilité du secteur et je pense
qu'il faut absolument que y ait des
fonds d'urgence de solidarité pour le
spectacle vivant notamment mais pas
seulement
et ce sera forcément aussi démontrer que
la culture est très diverse dans ses
approches que les acteurs fonctionne de
façon très différente et que pour cela
et bien c'est presque du cousu main ou
en tout cas il va falloir s'atteler à
des fonds d'urgence et de solidarité
très très vite vous parler du problème
de la billetterie effectivement on peut
craindre que malgré toutes les
précautions et bien le public ne soit
pas au rendez vous c'est aussi ça la
difficulté
absolument non seulement ils perdent la
billetterie mais on ne sait pas du tout
demain ce comment va réagir
public et je crois que cette incertitude
est encore plus difficile pour à la fois
je sais bien je le comprends anticiper
sur sur ce qu'on doit faire pour le
secteur culturel
d'où la nécessité de le penser
aujourd'hui avec eux jeudi avec eux mais
aussi avec les collectivités
territoriales qui sont en première ligne
qui finance beaucoup la culture et qui
attendent du gouvernement
un cadre clair et bien merci beaucoup et
sylvie robert d'avoir répondu à mes
questions rappelle que vous allez poser
tout à l'heure une question donc sur ce
secteur de la culture
j'ai maintenant le plaisir d'accueillir
le président du groupe union centriste
ici au sénat hervé marseille bonjour ont
discuté bien depuis hier ici au sénat du
budget rectificatif numéro 2 le deuxième
qui est présenté le plan d'urgence qui
est doté de 110 milliards d'euros par le
gouvernement
il ya plusieurs amendements notamment de
la gauche pour un retour de li sf est ce
que vous êtes favorable en cette période
de crise à mieux faire contribuer et
bien les plus hauts revenus
non nous sommes pas favorables à un
retour de li sf
ce n'est pas un plan de finances
rectificatif fourre tout où on va
ramener tout ce qui a été supprimée dans
le passé qui a pas nécessairement marché
lisf est un débat qui a eu lieu
ça a été transformée il ya maintenant un
autre impôt au lit fille qui fonctionne
bien a priori qui a du rendement
donc il n'y est pas question à nos yeux
de revenir sur sur ce débat on n'en est
plus là également à ce que vous êtes
favorable 1 déconfinement pour le coup
par région c'est un président de région
se prononcent là-dessus estime que ça
serait ça l'une des solutions possibles
car toutes les régions ne sont pas
atteintes au même niveau est ce que
c'est une bonne solution pour vous oui
c'est une solution
la bonne ou c'est par les temps qui
courent on essaie d'être un peu les uns
et les autres pragmatique je crois que
s'il ya une leçon à tirer de tout ce qui
se passe c'est quand même le besoin de
proximité le besoin de réaction par
rapport au terrain
c'est la raison pour laquelle les élus
jouent
un rôle indispensable une fois de plus
on l'a vu avec les jets les jeunes et
encore face à cette crise ce sont les
maires ce sont les collectivités
territoriales qui joue un rôle majeur
parce qu'elles sont près des familles
sont sur le terrain et ils sont à même
de réagir avec souplesse alors que
l'état est lourdement administratif on
en a vu aujourd'hui toutes les
conséquences
alors la situation n'est pas la même
suivant les départements
quand vous êtes dans des secteurs ruraux
au centre de la france ont peur et
ouvrir le bistrot on peut rouvrir la
petite entreprise on peut ré ouvrir un
certain nombre d'activités
on est content que j'ai de tout faire à
paris de façon soviétique partir
j'allais dire du gosplan on en est plus
là il faut s'adapter au terrain et il
faudra en tirer les leçons en allant
vers plus de décentralisation
justement en parlant du terrain les
quartiers sensibles sont sous tension
notamment en région parisienne est ce
que cela vous inquiète
comment l'expliquez comment sortir pour
vous de cette situation
c'est très préoccupant je pense que une
fois de plus se repose
j'allais dire le problème des banlieues
on a regretté en son temps que jean
louis borloo n'est pas été entendu que
son plan n'est pas été utile
on a eu un faux plan serait d'ailleurs
intéressant de faire le bilan de ce qui
a été proposé puisqu'il n'a pas de bilan
et il faut vraiment s'occuper de ses
sites et de ses banlieues on voit
aujourd'hui la complexité avec le
chômage avec les difficultés qui vont
l'exacerbation des insultes et avec
cette situation de confinement dans ces
secteurs-là les inégalités vont se
conjuguer et s'additionner également
donc il faut pouvoir apporter des
solutions spécifiques et il n'est pas
j'allais dire malheureusement inattendue
que y ait ce genre de réaction dans des
cités où la vie est déjà difficile
une toute dernière question se projette
et bien sûr dans quelques jours il y
aura normalement un débat sur le
tracking qui est prévu au sénat le 29
avril est ce que vous voulez un vote
après l'annnonce de ce vote qui va avoir
lieu à l'assemblée nationale eh bien
mais ce que vous voulez un débat plus
globale comme le demande gérard larcher
dans un courrier envoyé au premier
ministre ce lundi et un petit peu plus
tard que le 29 avril
oui gérard larcher
a envoyé ce courrier après en avoir
parlé justement avec les responsables de
la majorité sénatoriale à l'évidence
parler du trekking seulement ça n'est
pas pertinent le tracking n'est qu'un
des éléments du déconfinement à quoi ça
sert de parler du tracking si vous
n'avez pas les tests s'ils n'avaient pas
les masses l'on parle pas du médicament
voire de la régionalisation du
déconfinement donc il faut un débat plus
globale et c'est ce que nous appelons de
nos voeux et un vote en votre pourquoi
pas mais ce qui est important c'est
devant un vote qui intéresse que l'aube
allemand le du confinement
eh bien merci beaucoup avait marqué
d'avoir répondu à mes questions je vais
à présent accueillir emmanuel capus
emmanuel capus bonjour vous êtes
sénateur les indépendants de maine et
loire
première question six entreprises sur
dix ont recours au chômage partiel
monial pénicaud l'a confirmé ce matin
elle semble inquiète le gouvernement
s'en inquiète
est ce que vous partagez son inquiétude
est ce qu'il faut que et bien il y ait
plus de personnes qui travaillent en
france que que l'activité reprenne plus
rapidement ce qui est certain c'est que
je pense qu'il n'y aura pas de reprise
100 entreprises donc il faut à la fois
avoir le chômage partiel aujourd'hui
pour que les entreprises puissent
reprendre très rapidement
et effectivement je pense que dès
maintenant les entreprises qui n'ont
aucune raison d'être de s'arrêter
doivent pouvoir reprendre le travail le
plus rapidement possible et qu'on a
peut-être été un peu trop loin dans
l'arrêt de certaines entreprises qui
mènerait pas l'obligation de le faire
elles sont soumises à des injonctions
contradictoires à entre le respect des
conditions sanitaires les difficultés et
puis les injonctions économique
foued le paquet doit être mis
aujourd'hui pour rassurer pas plus tôt
pour que les chefs d'entreprise soient
rassurés et aient les moyens d'appliquer
les consignes sanitaires pour que leurs
salariés ne prennent pas de risques
démesurés et qu'ils puissent reprendre
leur poste au plus vite
bruno retailleau propose ce matin la
semaine à 37 heures pendant la période
de crise
le bref le retour du travail et plus
peut-être pour gagner plus est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cette
proposition
je crois pas que ce soit le sujet
aujourd'hui ce qui est certain c'est que
je pense qu'il faudra travailler
beaucoup pour pouvoir sortir de la crise
on est dans la situation la pire qu'on
ait connue depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale
donc c'est sûr qu'on ne s'en sortira pas
comme ça on va voter un plfr avec une
dette abyssale qui va peser sur les
générations futures
donc on n'en sortira pas sans travail et
je sais pas si c'est en travaillant plus
de 37 dauphin 37 eur ou 39 heures ou
plus ce qui est certain c'est qu'il
faudra travailler ça c'est certain
eh bien merci beaucoup emmanuel capus
d'avoir répondu à ma question puisque la
cloche a sonné voix gérard larcher le
président du sénat alors là que je n'a
pas encore sonné mais le président de
l'arche et ed installé pour commencer à
présider cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement pour
peut-être une toute dernière question
sur le budget rectificatif et les
crédits d'impôts les annulations de
charge très large que veut le sénat je
pense que c'est pas une mauvaise idée du
sénat que de toute façon le gouvernement
leurs effets dans les mois qui viennent
donc oui on a pu je pense qu'on a un peu
anticipée c'est une façon d'anticiper
parce que c'est une façon d'anticiper et
bien mercerie a beaucoup emmanuel capus
d'avoir répondu à mes questions et tout
de suite on va prendre la direction de
l'hémicycle pour cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
[Musique]
suivant les indications qui nous ont été
données et notamment par le médecin du
sénat et est un épidémiologiste de la
pitié salpêtrière
donc je demande à chacun d'être vraiment
attentif monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues je vous l'annoncé la
semaine passée c'est avec émotion que
nous avons appris la disparition de
christian bonnet le 7 avril dernier
profondément ancré dans son département
du morbihan christian bonnet a exercé
avec longévité quarante trois années
le mandat de conseiller général du
canton de belle-ile-en-mer 32 ans mère
de cartes
tout un symbole de solidité bretonne
élus à huit reprises des buts et du
morbihan
il a siégé 18 années sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale
il participa au gouvernement pendant
près d'une dizaine d'années secrétaire
d'état au logement ministre de
l'agriculture puis ministre de
l'intérieur
il fit le choix de rejoindre le sénat
c'était en 1983 il le quitta un moment
de sa décision de se retirer la vie
publique
c'était en 2001 au cours de ses mandats
sénatoriaux il fut une véritable
référence de la commission des lois
il y fut le rapporteur incontournable de
tous les textes concernant les questions
électorales sujet il demeure d'actualité
et la transparence financière de la vie
politique
il était un fervent défenseur du
bicamérisme il laisse le souvenir d'un
serviteur de l'état
chaque année le souvenir rigoureux
exigeant et d'un grand parlementaire
j'en ai le souvenir moi même
personnellement ici
voilà pourquoi j'ai souhaité exprimer au
nom du sénat notre sympathie à sa
famille à ses proches et lui rendre cet
hommage au début de notre séance
ici il siégeait dans le groupe des
indépendants ici qui était aussi la
marque de son tempérament de son
caractère je vous propose d'observer
quelques instants de silence
remercie j'ai le premier ministre et
dams et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement sous le forme adaptée
élargi depuis cette semaine notre séance
et retransmise en direct sur public
sénat il faut remettre site internet
leur donner la parole d'abord à notre
collègue guillaume gontard pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes avaient la parole
merci monsieur le monsieur le président
madame la ministre du travail depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire les
personnels de santé les caissiers les
livreurs les éboueurs les agriculteurs
les postiers et tant d'autres exposent
chaque jour leur santé pour assurer les
fonctions vitales du pays alors que leur
sécurité sanitaire est loin d'être
toujours assuré vous appeler à la
reprise de l'activité non essentiels
mais avec quelles garanties sanitaires
les mains sont ils arrivés en quantité
suffisante les entreprises sont elles
prêtes à s'organiser face à un risque
biologique invisible quel accompagnement
prévoit l'état repenser l'organisation
du travail comme la justice l'a rappelé
à amazon est une nécessité impérative
dans ce contexte que l'inspection du
travail est indispensable pour
accompagner les entreprises et garantir
la sécurité sanitaire des travailleurs
pourtant lieu de donner aux inspecteurs
les moyens d'exercer leurs missions vous
entre avait honteusement leurs actions
en effet la direction générale du
travail exige désormais des inspecteurs
de faire valider par leur hiérarchie
tout visites en entreprise ou tout
saisine du juge des référés une
disposition contraire à la convention
numéro 81 de l'oit et qui assure
l'autonomie de leur action pire encore
le drh de votre propre ministère a
suspendu la specter anthony smith sa
faute
exiger d'une entreprise d' aide à
domicile après une alerte des
représentants du personnel qu'elle
fournisse des masses pour protéger
salariés comme usagers un comble des
pressions inacceptables plongée d'une
plainte légitime contre la france
transmise par quatre syndicats obésité
alors madame la ministre nous vous
demandons d'abroger les ordres illégaux
de la dgt d'abandonner les sanctions et
menaces sur les inspecteurs du travail
et de leur fournir les moyens juridiques
et matériels de travailler en sécurité
ce sont des pré-requis impérative
à la reprise de l'activité et à défaut
vous fait prendre aux salariés de ces
risques sanitaires et psychosociaux
merci pour vos réponses de la parole
d'abn amro ministre du travail madame
pénicaud vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur guillaume goutard
d'abord merci de mettre en lumière
l'action de l'inspection du travail
je voudrais saluer cette occasion le
travail remarquable qu'elle fout mais
mon ami ce que fait mon administration
ou plan national et au plan des directs
et des unions départementales temps pour
le financement du chômage partiel qui
touche aujourd'hui et qui protège 10
millions de salariés dans notre pays que
pour l'inspection du travail qui est un
rôle majeur
vous l'avez rappelé en matière de santé
de protection du travail alors le 17
mars la direction générale du travail
qui est l'autorité centrale de
l'inspection du travail conformément aux
règles de l'oit et a donné des
instructions pour pouvoir permettre les
contrôles en terme de sécurité et santé
du travail afin de protéger les
travailleurs tout haut protégeant eux
mêmes les inspections du travail
c'est pour ça qu'il y a une information
une discussion préalable avec leurs
autorités pour vérifier ensemble que le
contrôle se faire sur place sans danger
ou s'il doit se faire sur pièce et
évidemment il ya beaucoup de mesures qui
sont prises sur les gestes barrières son
utilisation seuls des véhicules et 60
mille masques qui ont été dégagés pour
le ministère du travail pour permettre
notamment aux inspecteurs du travail de
pouvoir faire leurs contrôles en toute
sécurité là où c'est nécessaire
alors jamais le ministère du travail non
seulement n'entrave mais n'interdit des
interventions au contraire c'est son
rôle et l'organisation internationale du
travail est clair l'inspection n'est pas
une addition d'agents et un système
global qui doit protéger les salariés de
notre pays qui doit aussi conseiller les
entreprises et qui dans ce cadre-là
fonctionne alors vous m'interrogez aussi
sur un cas particulier la direction
générale du travail a suspendu de ses
fonctions à titre conservatoire un
inspecteur du travail de la marne qui
avait enfreint à plusieurs reprises de
façon délibérée et grave
les instructions de l'autorité centrale
il avait enjoint aux employeurs des
conditions de maintien d'activités
contraires aux prescriptions des
autorités sanitaires était intervenu
hors de sa compétence et à développer
des pratiques internes non déontologique
rapport
instruction il ya une procédure
disciplinaire en cours il aura tous les
moyens tout en conservant son traitement
selon le droit de défendre et d'imposer
ses arguments je crois que le service
public est attendu dans les entreprises
par là ça vaille et par les entreprises
plus que jamais nous devons être
irréprochables second tard pour quelques
secondes je vous ai je vais bien je vais
bien entendu mais un vous n'avez pas
répondu allez vous lever les sanctions
sur anthony smith
allez vous cesser la pression parce que
c'est une pression sur les inspecteurs
du travail
en fait en un mot laissé les inspecteurs
du travail faire faire leur travail et
travailler conformément au droit
international et au code du travail
c'est tout ce qu'on vous demande et
c'est pour le le bien et la santé des
travailleurs et des travailleuses
merci la parole est à notre collègue
sylvie robert pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la culture et de la
communication
le rideau est tombé sur tous les lieux
et les manifestations culturelles et
personne ne sait aujourd'hui quand il va
se relever
la culture est en danger et beaucoup de
ces artistes intermittents technicien
auteurs et les structures qui les
emploient sont déjà en mode survie
et pourtant elle ne s'est jamais révéler
aussi essentiels que dans cette période
de confinement ou à travers leurs
créations numériques ou grâce à la
qualité de notre audiovisuel public
les créateurs nous enchante
quotidiennement et nous aide à résister
mais l'été sera sûrement silencieux et
l'automne s'annonce très périlleux car
un certain si le secteur culturel a pu
bénéficier des dispositifs dead et c'est
important même si parfois ceux-ci sont
inadaptées est encore insuffisant il a
besoin de visibilité de visibilité
aujourd'hui pour construire les
programmations de demain de visibilité
aujourd'hui pour limiter les pertes déjà
énorme qu'il subit de visibilité enfin
pour anticiper et agir dans un cadre
réglementaire et précis et ce n'est pas
en annonçant que des petits festivals
est d'abord qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
petit festival pourrait avoir lieu le 11
mai après le 11 mai que vous rassurer
les acteurs les organisateurs mais aussi
les collectivités territoriales qui sont
depuis le début en première ligne et qui
ne demande qu'à être associés
parce que nous savons que ce secteur est
fragile qu'il est lié à un écosystème
global qu'il est essentiel à nos vies et
que nous aurons toujours et peut-être
plus encore besoin des artistes à quand
un plan d'urgence concerter avec les
collectivités territoriales et les
acteurs culturels
monsieur le ministre demain ne peut
attendre pour vous répondre la parole et
au ministre de la culture
franck riester merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs sénateurs madame la sénatrice
vous avez raison le secteur de la
culture est particulièrement touchée par
cette crise c'est évidemment dramatique
tant d'un point de vue économique
sociale sociétale psychologique je pense
à tous ces artistes à toutes celles et
ceux qui travaillent dans le secteur
culturel et qui aujourd'hui ont
évidemment des spectacles d'annuler ne
peuvent pas continuer ce qui était prévu
dans cette période là avec des
conséquences financières pour eux et des
conséquences psychologiques parce que
c'est parfois le fruit d'un travail de
long - de longues années qui est remis
complètement en question depuis le début
de cette crise
le ministère de la culture en lien avec
les autres ministères et sous l'autorité
du premier ministre a fait en sorte que
tous les dispositifs transversaux puisse
accompagner aussi des secteurs de la
culture
nous avons veillé à ce que les
intermittents les auteurs tous les
acteurs de la culture puisse d'une
manière brio de bénéficier des
dispositifs transversaux qui ont été mis
en place
nous allons veiller aussi à ce que des
dispositifs spécifiques d'urgence tout
de suite mobilisables à travers nos
opérateurs puissent être mis en oeuvre
et accessible pour celles et ceux qui en
avaient le plus besoin il mais il reste
du travail il reste du travail pour
qu'il n'ait que personne ne reste à côté
de ces aides d'urgence et il reste du
travail pour accompagner non seulement
le déconfinement et c'est tout le
travail de préparation du déconfinement
qu'il ne se fera que de façon évidemment
progressive mais aussi d'accompagnement
du rebond pour que demain des spectacles
demain des commerces culturels demain
des salles de cinéma demain des
tournages puisse recommencer et nous
aurons besoin de continuer à travailler
ensemble gouvernement collectivités
territoriales acteurs de la culture
parlementaire pour faire en sorte que
nous réussissions en
semble ce rebond du monde de la culture
j'étais en audition à la commission des
affaires culturelles du sénat la semaine
dernière par visioconférence comme vous
savez je suis rentré en détail dans
beaucoup de sujets et vous pouvez
compter sur moi pour continuer d'être en
plein dialogue avec le sénat sur ce
sujet la culture les français en ont
beaucoup besoin ils l'ont démontré
pendant le confinement et le démontrera
aussi après le déconfinement onab robert
oui merci monsieur le ministre je l ai
déjà dit à l'édition je crois que les
acteurs culturels et les collectivités
territoriales ont besoin d'anticiper ils
ont besoin de se projeter et pour cela
il faut des règles précises certes il va
y avoir des modalités de sortie de
confinement mais d'ores et déjà il faut
des protocoles et des règles qui vont
les aider à construire ce que va être
forcément la culture demain et ce ne
sera pas la même chose
notre modèle culturel et peut être
menacée faisons attention monsieur le
ministre
merci la parole est à notre collègue
jérôme bignon
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires
mais je lui monsieur le ministre de la
santé alors que le confinement sont
produire ses premiers effets et autorise
un optimisme prudent prudent les
professionnels de santé s'alarme de la
désertification de leur cabinet le
directeur de la cnam a observé un recul
de 40 à 50% de la consommation des soins
aussi bien en métier général que dans
différentes spécialités
vous l'avez vous même souligné récemment
la filière cancérologie particulièrement
touché dans la somme
aucun dépistage de cancer du sein n'a
été effectué depuis le début du
confinement de nombreux patients
renoncent à se rendre aux urgences par
peur de la contagion
le président des chirurgiens de la ph et
de l'ap-hp a observé une chute de 74%
des apps ainsi discectomie d'un
établissement parisien
les victimes d'avc et d'infarctus les
malades du diabète mais également les
personnes atteintes de troubles
psychiatriques voient leur état
s'aggraver de nombreux praticiens appels
à une réévaluation d'urgence des soins
de déprogrammer la rupture dans la
continuité des soins des soins est
particulièrement dommageable pour les
personnes âgées et ou handicapées
faute d'équipements de protection
suffisant les aides à domicile n'assure
plus les soins courants pour ces
personnes dans les maternités le
dépistage néonatal
réalisée au troisième jour après la
naissance permettant une prise en charge
précoce
le cinq maladies graves et désorganisée
faute de portage postale efficace des
retards de vaccination sont aussi
observées chez les nourrissons et les
jeunes enfants
monsieur le ministre une nouvelle vague
de mortalité différente cette fois
pourrait également se dessiner pourriez
vous dresser un bilan de l'impact
sanitaire du renoncement aux soins mais
aussi nous dire ce que vous pensez de
cette extraordinaire paradoxe
nos compatriotes ne se soignent plus
assez pour beaucoup de mots qui sont
fondamentaux et se précipitent de façon
déraisonnable semble-t-il sur la
nicotine à la moindre rumeur alors que
diabétique hypertension vax vaccins
devraient se soigner il préfère discuter
de la méthode de la nicotine
y at-il à bénéfices à choisir ce nouveau
sujet de conversation un monsieur le
ministre des solidarités de la santé
pour répondre à la question monsieur le
sénateur bignon merci pour votre
question c'est vrai nous sommes inquiets
nous sommes inquiets par le constat
qu'un certain nombre de français
semblent renoncer à des soins essentiels
utile
certains sont atteints de maladies
chroniques certains ne sont pas malades
mais renonça du dépistage de cancers
cancer du sein cancer colorectal
certaines femmes enceintes n'ont pas
forcément eu toutes les échographies
obstétricales dont elles doivent
pourtant bénéficié et la vaccination est
en diminution inquiétante c'est pourquoi
nous multiplions nous multiplions depuis
plusieurs semaines les messages à la
population la possibilité d'aller voir
son médecin est une dérogation total à
la l'obligation de rester chez soi même
c'est à dire que pour aller voir son
médecin on peut se déplacer
par ailleurs la télémédecine a été mise
en place très tôt très vite nous avons
dépassé la semaine dernière le seuil du
million de consultations réalisées en
télémédecine c'est aussi une solution
qui peuvent être proposées par les
médecins lorsqu'il ne souhaitent pas
nécessairement que la normale à leurs
patients se déplace j'ai appelé les
présidents de syndicats de médecins
aussi qui m'ont dit eux-mêmes avoir des
démarches qui consiste à aller vers les
patients les contacts et lorsqu'ils
n'ont pas de nouvelles de ses patientes
que ça depuis un certain temps donc
merci pour votre
salutaire rappel je voulais en profiter
également pour vous répondre sur la
question la nicotine une équipe de
chercheurs français a effectivement
écrit un article scientifique
intéressant une étude observationnelle
qui tend à montrer que il y a moins de
malades dans la population consommatrice
de nicotine en l'occurrence de fumeurs
que dans le reste mais attention et vous
avez raison de souligner attention ça ne
veut pas dire que le tabac protège le
tabac y tu y as plus de 70 mille morts
par an bien réels liés au tabac la
consommation de tabac dans notre pays
par contre ça veut dire que une piste
intéressante parmi d'autres pistes de
recherche clinique consisterait à
essayer de comprendre par quels
mécanismes biochimiques la nicotine pour
est en elle-même être un marqueur de
lutte contre eux et ou de résistance
face à cette maladie
j'attire vraiment l'attention de nos
concitoyens parce que vous avez raison
de le rappeler il sont promptes à aller
se précipiter parce qu'ils ont peur ils
sont inquiets ils n'ont pas toutes les
réponses des études cliniques sont
désormais en cours de construction vont
être menées par des équipes
universitaires de grand talent de très
grand talent dans les hôpitaux français
permettant de comprendre permettant de
chercher de décrypter et éventuellement
des d'identifier si nous pourrions par
le biais de la nicotine avoir des effets
positifs c'est un certain nombre de
malades et dans quelles conditions donc
surtout même quelqu'un qui se dirait je
vais mettre un patch de nicotine
attention quelqu'un qui n'est pas fumeur
qui ma page de nicotine il va le sentir
passer tout de suite un les vomissements
les étourdissements les malaises
certainement pas un traitement
certainement pas d'automédication
certainement pas une voie d'entrée dans
la consommation de nicotine
attention c'est un produit addictif mais
par contre nous ne fermons jamais aucune
porte et nous verrons certainement pas
celle là
d'autant qu'elle est portée par des
équipes de grand talent des hôpitaux
français merci la parole est à notre
collègue alain joyandet pour le groupe
l'est républicain
vous avez la parole du shérif merci
monsieur le président le premier
ministre et messieurs les ministres
questions essentielles s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur mais
auparavant je voudrais aborder deux
sujets pour attirer l'attention du
gouvernement d'abord sur la situation
des outre-mer face aux plans de
sauvetage des entreprises notre collègue
michel magras ce nous alerte sur le fait
que ce plan devrait être sans doute
adapter aux outremers parce que sont
selon lui
selon la délégation qu'il préside ces
dispositions ne correspondent pas tout à
fait à la structure des entreprises là
bas j'attire votre attention sur ce
sujet autre sujet celui des communes qui
pour l'instant perdre comme les
entreprises communes en france
perdre comme les entreprises et en
outre-mer aussi sans doute sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire national
et outre-mer les communes qui perdent
des recettes en liaison avec leurs
pertes d'activité qui continuent à payer
les salaires comme les entreprises
notamment celles qui ont des activités
un peu commerciale comme la culture les
piscines un certain nombre de dossiers
sur lesquels il ya des recettes et pour
lequel n'y a pas de compensation mais un
maintien des salaires j'en viens
maintenant à ma question essentielle qui
concerne la question de la sécurité
les banlieues flambent à nouveau
monsieur le ministre
dans de nombreux endroits evreux
bordeaux villeneuve la garenne
chanteloup-les-vignes nos forces de
l'ordre sont mises en cause sont
attaqués quasiment 1 et donc nous sommes
pour ne pas faire de stigmatisation un
peu un peu discret un exemple concret un
un homme de 30 ans condamné 14 x qui a
attaqué les forces de l'ordre force
immédiatement mise en cause on a envie
de dire ça suffit
et puis cette occasion que l'ensemble de
la représentation nationale réaffirme
une fois de plus notre soutien à nos
forces de sécurité savez dans cette
crise sanitaire
nous apportons notre soutien nous
faisons bloc il faut pas en plus laissé
se développer une une crise dans nos
banlieues comme c'était le cas en 2005
je crois que ça ne serait pas
supportable ne pouvons pas vraiment
ajouter une crise sécuritaire à une
crise sanitaire monsieur le ministre
vous pouvez ouvrir la parole pour nous
répondre et aux milices de l'intérieur
monsieur christophe castaner merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur joyan
des vous avez raison sur un principe qui
doit tous nous rassembler les règles de
respect du confinement doivent
s'appliquer et être contrôlée par tous
de la même façon sur notre territoire
il n'y a pas de quartier dans lequel nos
forces de sécurité d'intérieur
n'interviendrait pas et je voudrais
profiter de votre question pour mettre
un terme à ce que j'ai pu lire ou
entendre ça n'était pas le sens de votre
question
selon lequel les forces de sécurité vers
nos policiers et nos gendarmes selon les
territoires n'interviendrait pas dans
les quartiers je ne tiens pas de
statistiques quartier par quartier
mais je vais prendre quelques exemples
marseille marseille où chaque soir nos
services dress 300 procès verbaux pour
infraction aux règles du confinement
dont les deux tiers sont dans les cités
de marseille en seine saint denis au
cours de ces dernières semaines
chaque soir trois opérations sont
coordonnées dans les cités sensibles
avec l'appui de moyens aériens pour
contrôler ce qu'il s'y passe et
globalement ce sont 220 milles contrôle
qui ont eu lieu et 33000 38000
verbalisation c'est un peu à peu près en
termes de contrôle le double de la
moyenne nationale et donc je voudrais
réaffirmer qu effectivement nous sommes
présents dans les quartiers pour agir et
pour contrôler et pour protéger celles
et ceux qui au fond en ne respectant pas
le confinement se met en risque mais il
est vrai que dans ces quartiers au
moment où nous intervenons il peut
arriver qu'il y ait des provocations
qu'il y ait des atteintes à nos forces
de sécurité des mises en cause de
l'utilisation de différents projectiles
contre nos forces de sécurité ces
dernières nuits vous l'avez rappelé en
particulier depuis samedi soir des
guets-apens ont été organisées et là
encore je vais vous dire que d'abord
nous les condamnons de la façon la plus
ferme et nous réagissons immédiatement
la nuit dernière une quinzaine de faits
se sont déroulés sur le territoire
national douze personnes ont été
interpellées depuis le week-end dernier
ce sont 28 qui ont été interpellés le
seul sénateur mesdames et sénateurs
n'ayant aucun doute nous veillons à
faire en sorte que le confinement soit
respectée
tout en france et partout nos forces de
sécurité intérieures sont mises en cause
sont provoquées nous leur devons
protection nous le faisons et nous
devons sanctionné cela de la façon la
plus ferme possible
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue pierre lehoux pour le groupe de
l'union centriste lever la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à olivier véran ministre de la
santé et je voudrais saluer monsieur le
ministre à cette occasion tout votre
travail le travail du gouvernement le
travail du premier ministre mais aussi
des directeurs et personnels de la rs et
bien sûr de tous les soignants
ce ne sont pas eux qui sont en cause à
travers ma question mais bien le système
comment expliquer que deux mois après
les expérimentations du professeur raoul
sur la chloroquine on ne sache toujours
rien sur l'efficacité de ce traitement
alors qu'une expérimentation la cible
aurait sans doute apporter des réponses
depuis un mois comment expliquer qu'il
est qu'il a il fallut attendre un mois
avant de répondre aux propositions des
laboratoires vétérinaires pour tester
plus largement les porteurs du coc vide
19 15 jours après les barrières
administratives leurs capacités de test
ne sont toujours pas utilisé
comment expliquer dans d'autres
circonstances on casse l'initiative
locale ont fait faire demi-tour à un
convoi sanitaire au péril des malades
parce que la décision n'a pas été privé
au bon endroit
comment expliquer aux dentistes
parfaitement organisé avec le chr
réclame toujours leur protection qui
leur sont nécessaires
comment faire confiance à un système qui
demain devra répartir les masques à tous
les français qui va coordonner tout cela
tous ces dysfonctionnements sont les
ailiers à la gestion bureaucratique
d'une administration qui coule sous les
lois règlements protocole complètement
inadaptée à une gestion de crise
monsieur le ministre gérer une crise
c'est oublier les contraintes
administratives
que comptez vous faire pour accélérer le
fonctionnement de notre système
administratif médical qui est
aujourd'hui dépassé
on vous répondre la parole et mobilise
des solidarités de la santé monsieur le
sénateur luo vous avez posé beaucoup de
questions je vais essayer de répondre
du coup de manière rapide un maximum
d'entre elles sachez d'abord que la
france est le pays des études cliniques
j'en ai site est une tout à l'heure sur
la nicotine il m'a beaucoup qui sont en
cours sur l'hydrologie chloroquine mais
la france n'est pas la seule pays avec
terry mantel hydroxy chloroquine les
états unis d'autres pays européens et
les dernières publications monsieur le
sénateur que je vous invite à lire qui
ont été publiés et validé ne sont pas en
faveur
hélas mais clairement pas en faveur de
l'utilisation en pratique courante de ce
traitement en mono ou en bithérapie
associé à l'isro micinn néanmoins des
études continuent sur l'ensemble du
territoire national dans les hôpitaux
et donc nous aurons des réponses
également issues d'études françaises
mais lisez la publication américaine
d'hier
je vous invite à beaucoup de prudence
encore plus qu'avant encore beaucoup
minci il n'ya pas le protocole docteur
out ya un médicament comprend quand on
est malade et qui est efficace ou qu'il
n'est pas après on peut dessiner ce que
c'est qu'un protocole clinique mais je
vous assure que un protocole clinique il
répond à des règles universelles de
publications scientifiques
internationales et qu'en l'occurrence
les publications qui sortent si vous
retrouvez une qui est validée qui permet
d'étendre la prescription serait encore
une fois le plus ravi les miss de la
santé parce qu'on aurait un traitement
efficace ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
et c'est mon rôle de le dire sur les
laboratoires vétérinaires monsieur le
sénateur ils ont été mobilisés ils ont
proposé à être mobilisés passer de la
médecine vétérinaire à la médecine
humaine c'est une première dans notre
pays et elle a été faite notamment grâce
à la mobilisation des ars et notamment
des préfets sur les évacuations
sanitaires je ne voudrais pas qu'on
retienne je n'aimerais pas qu'on
retienne des évacuations sanitaires
un bus qui a été emporté d'un hôpital à
un autre sans prévenir les autorités de
santé je voudrais qu'on retienne que
notre pays a réalisé six cent quarante
quatre évacuations sanitaires par train
par avion par hélicoptère nous sommes le
seul pays au monde à l'avoir fait c'est
une fierté française
j'étais en lien hier avec des
réanimateurs de l'hôpital de strasbourg
qui me racontait ce que savait
représenté comme chantier monumental
pour permettre de sauver des vies c'est
un motif de fierté et nous n'aurions pas
pu le faire sans interventions
permanentes des agences régionales de
santé et de ses agents j'ajoute qu'un
certain nombre d'entre eux ont payé un
lourd tribut
il ya eu des morts dans les ars monsieur
le sénateur et des gens qui ont continué
de travailler alors qu'ils étaient
malades parce que sans les agences
régionales de santé sans leurs agents
dans les territoires tout est
perfectible
tout système surtout administratif est
perfectible et je pourrais écrire un
roman sur les difficultés les longueurs
les problèmes logistiques administratifs
que connaît notre pays comme d'autres
mais encore une fois de rendre hommage
aux grands talents en agence et enfin
sur les dentistes leurs écrits hier ils
devront cent cinquante mille masques
ffp2 supplémentaires je crois que votre
question pour les remercier pour s'être
organisés pour assurer les urgences sur
tout le territoire depuis plusieurs
semaines le mélange dans les semaines à
venir les clients et après je vous
parlerai du charbon bactéries dhien
c'est un vétérinaire qui l'a mis au
point au 19e siècle
mais monsieur le haut oui monsieur le
ministre le 11 mai on va passer d'une
guerre de tranchées à une guerre
d'action il va falloir être prêt et je
ne suis pas sûr qu'on soit prêt le 11
mai la parole et à d'autres collègues
xavier iacovelli pour le groupe de
république en marche
oui monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à adrien
taquet secrétaire d'état en charge de la
protection de l'enfance au moment où une
crise sanitaire inédite frappe notre
pays entraînant ainsi le confinement de
la population nos pensées vont tout
particulièrement aux plus vulnérables
d'entre eux c'est à dire nos enfants les
chiffres nous le connaissons 130000 la
fille et 35000 garçons subissent des
viols ou tentatives de viol chaque année
en majorité incestueux cent quarante
mille enfants sont exposés à des
violences conjugales
ces violences elle ne s'arrête pas
subitement durant le confinement
au contraire les risques sont décuplées
par l'impossibilité pour l'enfant de
trouver refuge dans la journée notamment
à l'école au sport ou chez des camarades
de classe
ces rares moments de répit où l'enfant
pouvait parler et s'échapper ne serait
ce qu'un instant aux violences qu'il
subit s'efface s'efface laissant place à
une solitude la plus totale je pense
également à ces milliers d'enfants
suivis dans le cadre d'une action
éducative en milieu ouvert et qui se
retrouve aujourd'hui 24 heures sur 24
avec leurs parents malgré les tensions
qui peuvent exister au sein des familles
je pense aux travailleurs sociaux qui
malgré leur dévouement tu plus le plus
total peine à assurer leurs missions
dans le contexte de crise sanitaire qui
bouleverse nos modes
de déplacement et qui subissent depuis
trop longtemps trop longtemps des coupes
budgétaires dans un grand nombre de
départements
ces quelques départements qui de manière
unilatérale et contre l'avis du juge
n'assure plus les visites médiatisées
qui rompt totalement les liens entre les
parents et les enfants
depuis près d'un mois et demi ces mêmes
départements qui au début du confinement
on renvoyait certains enfants dans leurs
familles malgré les risques encourus
je vous le dis car cette situation
dramatique
elle s'observe chez moi dans les
hauts-de-seine je pense enfin à ces
milliers de jeunes isolés hébergés dans
des hôtels sociaux et dont les moyens
matériels insuffisants ne permettent pas
de suivre un enseignement au même titre
que les autres jeunes face à cette
situation le gouvernement les
associations et la société dans son
ensemble se mobilisent
vous avez multiplié monsieur le ministre
les canaux permettant une meilleure
détection des violences je pense à
l'adaptation du 119 permettant ainsi les
signalements en ligne à l'augmentation
du nombre d'écoutants grâce notamment au
soutien des associations et à
l'élargissement du 114 pour les
violences intrafamiliales à cela vient
s'ajouter bien sûr la mobilisation des
associations des ong et des collectifs
d'anciens enfants placés qui lutte
contre les violences et soutiennent les
enfants en danger malgré tout monsieur
le ministre le confinant aura une fois
de plus démontré le dysfonctionnement
dramatique qui existe au sein de la zone
dans nos territoires et la disparités
d'un département à l'autre
alors ma question est simple monsieur le
ministre quelle mesure il était temps et
seront prises pour davantage protéger
des enfants des maltraitances et
soutenir les parents qui souvent pour
des raisons sociales économique peine à
soutenir pleinement leur rôle je le
ministre en deux minutes vous
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur + 89 %
monsieur le sénateur + 89 % c'est le
l'augmentation du nombre d'appels au 119
la semaine dernière plus 89%
ce que la famille qui est ce lieu de
protection d'amour d'épanouissement pour
l'enfant est aussi le lieu de
maltraitance de violence 89 %
d'augmentation ça ne nous surprend pas
c'est le signe de l'augmentation dès
violences pendant cette période de
confinement mais je veux y voir aussi le
signe le baromètre de notre vigilance
accrue à chacun d'entre nous et deux
autres chiffres vont dans ce sens la
semaine dernière
l'augmentation le nombre d'appels passés
par les voisins ont augmenté de 84%
par les camarades pour leur camarade a
doublé + 100 % les formulaires le
formulaire en ligne que nous avons mis
en place sur halo 119 points gouv.fr
recueille chaque semaine plus de 200
sésime donc tout cela fonctionne les
campagnes de communication que nous
avons lancé auprès des français
fonctionne mais encore faut-il que ces
appels ne reste pas sans réponse
nous avons vous l'avez évoqué augmenté
de 25 % le temps d'écouter des au sein
du 119 et je veux à cette occasion
remercier ses héros du quotidien que
sont les écoutant du 119 à côté des
travailleurs sociaux que vous mentionnez
j'ai dès le 21 mars dernier
encore la semaine dernière au téléphone
auprès de dominique bussereau et ce jour
même à l'occasion d'un courrier que je
lui fais parvenir saisi l'ensemble des
départements afin qu'ils assurent la
continuité et qui les effectifs soient
renforcés dans les cellules de recueil
d'informations préoccupantes afin de
recueillir les informations
préoccupantes et que des travailleurs
sociaux puissent aller mener des
enquêtes dans les familles où les
enfants sont en danger
et puis pour conclure monsieur le
président il faut commencer à penser à
l'après à l'après confinement quels sont
les effets psychologiques les effets sur
la santé mentale que ce confinement aura
eu sur nos enfants
comment allons-nous détecter les
violences qui auront eu cours pendant
cette période de confinement c'est un
des gros enjeu sur lequel nous
commençons à travailler avec le ministre
des solidarités et de la santé et où
l'éducation nationale notamment aura un
grand rôle à jouer un jour merci merci
la parole est maintenant aux présidents
gabouty pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame jacqueline gourault
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des collectivités locales et j'y
associe mon collègue raymond vall et
l'ensemble des membres du groupe rdse
comme l'a très justement rappelé le
président de la république et vous même
monsieur le premier ministre les
collectivités locales représentent un
maillon essentiel dans le dispositif de
mise en oeuvre des mesures nationales et
d'accompagnement des populations face à
la crise du corona virus et départements
les opci et les communes avec leurs
services sociaux ou les ccas ont fait
preuve d'une très grande réactivité dans
des domaines comme le soutien aux
familles en difficulté le lien avec les
populations fragiles la livraison de
repas à domicile ou de courses de
première nécessité de contacts réguliers
avec des personnes âgées ou isolées ou
encore l'acquisition et la distribution
de masques les régions en plus de la
participation au fonds solidarité ont
pour la plupart mis en place des
dispositifs complémentaires des deux
entreprises
avec parfois des possibilités de
délégation par convention au département
ep6 et communes comme par exemple dans
la région hôte france cependant beaucoup
de petites structures
malgré leur éligibilité au fonds de
solidarité qui est indispensable mais
peut-être pas suffisant seront
confrontés pendant plusieurs mois à les
difficultés récurrentes mettant en cause
leur pérennité
les interlocuteurs les mieux placés pour
accompagner sur le plan économique ces
micro-entreprises auto entrepreneurs
travailleurs indépendants artisans
commerçants seul ou avec un ou deux
salariés semblent être les collectivités
de proximité c'est à dire les
départements les ep si les communes qui
peuvent le mieux appréhender leurs
besoins aujourd'hui la législation ne
leur permet pas d'intervenir seul
directement en soutien financier à ces
petites entreprises sous forme par
exemple des avances remboursables ou de
prise en charge de loyer peut-on
envisager avec bien sûr un encadrement
législatif et réglementaire strict de
ou pire à titre exceptionnel et pour une
durée limitée
les textes qui régissent l'exercice de
cette compétence économique dette
directe aux tpe
quel que soit leur statut je suis
persuadé la réactivité des collectivités
de cale dans ce domaine aussi et qu'elle
peut utilement venir compléter amplifier
les dispositifs que nous mettons en
place au niveau national pour vous
répondre
la parole est à madame jacqueline
gourault mini de la cohésion des
territoires des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur jean marc gabouty je vous
remercie d'abord d'avoir rappelé le rôle
important des collectivités
territoriales et vous m'interrogez plus
précisément sur la participation
financière aux entreprises des
territoires
comme vous le savez c'est la région qui
est compétente pour définir les aides
les régimes dead et pour attribuer les
aides directes aux entreprises les
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale peuvent adopter des aides
immobilière aux entreprises
il faut aussi le rappeler par ailleurs
les opci peuvent participer au fonds mis
en oeuvre par les régions ils le font
aujourd'hui dans différents mécanismes
par exemple des fonds qui s'appelle fond
de résilience qui ont été mises en
oeuvre par de nombreuses régions les
départements en revanche ne peuvent pas
financer des aides aux entreprises nées
en mettant en place un fonds personnels
ni en participant aux fonds régionaux
sauf si ce fonds vise à financer les
secteurs qui relèvent de la compétence
du département
je pense par exemple à l'économie
sociale et solidaire
cette règle je pense qu'il faut s'y
tenir
en effet dans cette période compliquée
nous ne vont pas nous ne devons pas
pardon disperser nos forces et vous avez
rappelé vous même le rôle très important
des départements dans l'exercice des
compétences sociales et nous pensons
tous n'est ce pas que ces dépenses
sociales vont évidemment
augmenter dans la situation que nous
vivons aujourd'hui je pense à toutes les
aides que vous avez cité la politique de
l'enfance le financement des allocations
de solidarité le soutien aux personnes
âgées
enfin toutes les politiques sociales du
département par ailleurs et je voulais
rappeler
nous avons déjà ouvert des souplesses en
permettant aux départements et aux
autres collectivités de participer au
fonds national qui je le rappel s'élève
à 7 milliards avec plus de 6 milliards
de participations de l'état et 500
millions des régions le gouvernement
encourage les communes d un pci et même
les départements à participer à ce fonds
national et cette participation est très
intéressante
bien évidemment parce qu'elle permet de
coordonner nos forces et je rappelle par
ailleurs qu'à titre dérogatoire les
collectivités par qui participent à ce
qu'au pénal voient leurs dépenses de
caucourt inscrits en dépenses
d'investissement
je vous remercie merci la parole est
maintenant notre collègue catherine
procaccia pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole mes chers collègues
merci à monsieur le président monsieur
le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres alors que
l'allègement du confinement et pendant
19 jours
la dernière conférence de presse de
monsieur le premier ministre à apporter
aux français plus de questionnements que
de réponses même si nous avons compris
que le plan du gouvernement était
toujours en construction
la gravité de la situation et des enjeux
impose de répondre rapidement à
certaines questions clés celle des
masques est essentielle d'abord parce
que la plupart des français veulent
l'emporter pour protéger les autres et
pour l'impact psychologique de son port
comme le dit notre colère jean françois
rapin qui rappelle que l'on vit une
épidémie et que le le masque conforte
les gestes barrière un lien français de
la vente en ligne met en vente avec
votre accord 60 millions de masques
chirurgicaux pour les entreprises alors
que vous n'avez toujours pas répondu
clairement aux pharmaciens dont c'est
pourtant le métier qui vous interpellent
pour savoir s'ils peuvent ou non vendre
à prix coûtant des masques aux tissus ou
chirurgicaux
comme cela si on démasque grand public
premier par le président comment va
s'effectuer la distribution si ce sont
les collectivités qui en sont chargés il
faut leur dire comment se signaler qu'en
auprès de qui peut elle passer commande
la date de la livraison effective et si
c'est à elle de les payer
devant elle priorise et certaines
populations bref quand auront terre
rapidement des consignes claires
à trois semaines du déconfinement
progressif je râlais des questions
simples de mes collègues qui quand
combien comment si évident ah oui là et
là ça m'a pris je vous fais des comptes
au lait dans une journée d'été 500 mieux
sorti que l'état jusqu'à maintenant
notamment dans la stratégie
d'approvisionnement masques chirurgicaux
ou alternatifs elles ont besoin d
aujourd'hui d'informations claires pour
préparer cette phase tout comme il faut
leur répondre maintenant et non le 11
mai sur les transports scolaires la
restauration du midi
la désinfection des équipements ou la
réouverture des lieux publics
pardon ma chère collègue l'apparent
l'état au ministre de la santé de la
solidarité et monsieur véran pour
répondre à vos questions multiples merci
madame la sénatrice pro cassia pour
votre pour votre question le premier
ministre j'étais présent à ses côtés a
tenu dimanche une conférence de presse
qui est rentré dans les détails et qui a
porté un s'attendre d'information il a
notamment été question je crois en
transparence de la question des masques
jeudi des masques puisque vous l'avez
souligné vous même et je jouerai sûr
qu'il n'y ait pas de confusion
je vais peut-être et puis c'est de
répondre du mieux possible à vos
questions d'abord il ya des masques
soignant ses masques ils sont dédiés aux
soignants ce sont les masques ffp2 et
les masques chirurgicaux
ce sont des masques destinés aux
soignants pour lequel nous avons passé
des commandes massives en chine que nous
produisons également en france qui sont
distribués gratuitement par les
pharmacies puisque l'état leur livre
gratuitement ces masques cette
distribution de masques nous nous allons
l'étendre progressivement aux personnes
malades aux personnes contacts mais
également à des personnes
avec un état de santé particulièrement
vulnérable sur prescription médicale
ils continueront ces masques d'être
donnés aux patients à partir des stocks
d'état ça les choses sont très claires
et ensuite il ya les masques grand
public qui sont pas des masques en tissu
lambda madame la sénatrice et je
voudrais surtout pas et c'est là tout
l'enjeu de la discussion que nous avons
les masques grand public ne sont pas des
masques qu'on peut fabriquer à la maison
à partir d'un morceau de tissu d'une
écharpe ou d'un ou d'un drap les masques
grand public
attention à leur appellation peut-être
trop peu je suis ce que veut montrer un
masque qui n'en est pas un et masques
grand public sont des masques filtrants
extrêmement filtrant certains filtres à
70%
la plupart filtre au delà de 90 % des
particules qui font de 1 à 3 microns
donc les particules qui transporte le
virus ce sont des masques protecteurs
pour lesquelles nous avons lancé toutes
les entreprises textiles partante avec
nous dans cette aventure à l'échelle du
pays
plus de 100 entreprises et nous
produisons des dizaines de millions de
ces masques pour pouvoir les rendre
disponibles progressivement pour les
français qui en relèvent
et à terme peut-être pour l'ensemble
donc attention il faut pas qui de
confusion entre les deux les pharmaciens
j'ai répondu hier mais je vous réponds à
nouveau volontiers les pharmaciens sont
évidemment évidemment fondé à participer
à cette distribution des masques je le
dis pour les masques soignants ils en
ont le monopole mais pour les masquer
grand public également de même pourquoi
pas que les grandes surfaces de même que
les entreprises de même que les mairies
vous avez raison de souligner le que les
maires sont un maillon essentiel dans
les territoires ils ont vocation à
participer à cet effort collectif de
protection de la population faut
conclure merci oui oui vous aviez les
arrêts de jeu wasit merci messieurs le
ministre merci mais vous n'avez pas
répondu à la question les collectivités
doivent tels que doivent-elles passer
commande
comment vont elles avoir des masques les
pharmaciens pour l'instant
réglementairement ils ont pas le droit
de pouvoir
même les vendre à prix coûtant que ce
soit les matchs chirurgicaux certains
peuvent s'en procurer puisque ces
disques où nous faisons pour ne pas
nommer s'en procure eux aussi sont
capables de le faire
vous n'avez pas apporter ses réponses et
on est à trois semaines de du début du
déconfinement et tous ceux qui veulent
partir
à l'effort ne savent pas comment
participer à l'effort merci la parole
est maintenant à notre collègue patrice
joly pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
vous avez la parole ce président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le projet de loi de finances
rectificative qui est soumis à nos
débats en ce moment est un projet en
trompe l'oeil
les montants annoncés sont gonflés par
rapport à la réalité des crédits
nouvellement mobiliser pas 110 milliards
comme le dit le gouvernement mais
seulement 42 si l'on entre dans le
détail des dépenses même si elles
répondent en partie aux besoins des
entreprises le compte n'y est pas pour
les plus modestes ayant tête monsieur le
ministre la crise des gilet jaune qui a
témoigné de la fracture sociale de notre
pays
ayez en tête monsieur le ministre
l'augmentation de la pro b qui la
pauvreté identifiée par l'insee
en ce début d'année et qui va s'aggraver
brutalement avec les pertes d'emplois le
chômage partiel et la disparition
d'entreprises beaucoup trop de nos
concitoyens sont laissés sur le bas côté
nos étudiants nos intérimaires nous
retraités mais aussi les acteurs
culturels les organismes de solidarité
la liste est longue
le financement essentiellement par le
déficit et la dette ne fait que renvoyer
la charge à demain en la lissant il est
urgent que les plus aisés fortement
avantagé depuis le début de ce
quinquennat prennent leur part à
l'effort national
alors même que la crise oblige art
questionner les paradigmes libéraux le
dogmatisme conduit le gouvernement a
préféré
l'appel aux dons à la justice fiscale le
marché à la planification l'incitation à
la régulation
ce plfr ne permet pas aujourd'hui de
définir de grandes orientations par
rapport à la paix notamment sur les
politiques écologiques et
environnementales qui doivent pourtant
constituer une réponse aux causes de
cette épidémie
il nous faut renforcer le service public
sanitaire mais pas seulement
notre souveraineté sanitaire et
alimentaire mais pas seulement
il nous faut inventer un nouveau modèle
de mondialisation
notre pays a besoin d'un nouveau modèle
économique social écologique cela se
prépare dès maintenant avec le parlement
bien sûr et en particulier avec cette
assemblée
n'ayez pas peur du débat démocratique il
est seul à permettre de trouver les
réponses innovantes et partager
à une situation jusque là inconnu n'ayez
pas peur du débat sur la sécurité
sociale qui doit plus que jamais être
préservé mes thèmes étaient en
discussion un projet de loi rectificatif
de financement de la sécurité sociale
même si rien ne vous y oblige ma
question au gouvernement est simple
quand vous vous engagerez vous dans ces
départs quant à lui le groupe socialiste
et républicain il est prêt je vous
remercie pour vous répondre
il va prendre le micro et chacun sera
attentif à respecter les distances y
compris sur les bancs du premier rang
vous prenez le micro à votre tribord la
bac est libre non voilà la parole et ou
secrétaires d'état monsieur cedrico vous
avez la part aussi monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sept heures
monsieur le le sénateur je lis je pense
qu'il peut y avoir beaucoup de débats
monsieur le sénateur sur ce que devait à
quoi devrait ressembler la praye
éventuellement à ce à quoi ressemblait
l'avant je pense que faire le procès du
gouvernement sur une insuffisance
d'implication à la fois à destination du
tissu industriel français est à la fois
à destination des plus fragiles dans la
situation que nous connaissons en
regardant ce qui se fait autour de nous
et regardant le montant et le caractère
extrêmement massif de ce qui a été
déployé je pense que c'est un mauvais
procès monsieur le député monsieur le
sénateur par non et je pense que si vous
parlez à l'ensemble des bénéficiaires
notamment les plus petites entreprises
les tpe les pme le tissu industriel
les bénéficiaires de la ss des apl tout
seul du rsa tout cela vous diront que la
réalité de l'aide qui a été apportée et
massive quelques éléments relatifs aux
plfr que vous évoquez pour ne pas
rappeler que s'agissant des plus
fragiles ce notamment des bénéficiaires
du rsa et de la ssc 150 euros par enfant
et 400 euros socle pour les
bénéficiaires des apl ces 100 euros par
enfant 6 4 millions de ménages monsieur
le sénateur qui seront concernés par ces
aides pour le plfr il vise aussi à
soutenir nos pme nos tpe et nos
entreprises en grande difficulté
notamment avec le fonds de solidarité
qui passe de 1 milliards à six milliards
d'euros
notamment avec le fonds de développement
économique et social
qui passe à 1 milliard d'euros pour
aider les pme et les tpe françaises et
enfin un ensemble de dispositions qui
permettront à toutes nos entreprises en
difficulté à toutes nos entreprises qui
connaissent des difficultés qu'ils
connaissent une baisse de chiffre
d'affaires pour ne pas détruire notre
tissu industriel et pour ne pas sombrer
dans le chômage le rappelle aussi les
chiffres du chômage partiel déployés par
muriel pénicaud se sont 9,6 millions de
salariés et 7 185 1000 entreprises qui
en bénéficient le temps du débat sur l'
après le temps du débat sur ce à quoi
devrait ressembler après viendra mais je
pense que dans la situation le
gouvernement est à la hauteur de ce à
quoi attendre les français merci la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
nadia seul groupe pour le groupe de
l'union centriste avait la parole et les
ministres mes chers collègues nous
vivons depuis quelques semaines avec une
unique consigne
restez chez vous or arrive le moment où
il va falloir redémarrer une vie sociale
et professionnelle
au sens propre du terme nous mettre en
route reprendre une mobilité la question
de la mobilité a été au coeur de nos
récents débats ceux d'avant pour des
raisons environnementales impérieuse
nous avions tous pris la mesure de
l'enjeu des mobilités collective l'image
des transports publics venaient d'être
mise à mal par les mouvements sociaux et
l'impression d'une perte de qualité du
service
il fallait alors déjà à regagner le
coeur des usagers à cela va désormais
s'ajouter la peur pour sa santé car la
crise que nous traversons va poser
d'énormes problèmes sanitaires dans les
transports publics difficiles dit
respecter la règle de distanciation
sociale difficile d'éviter tout contact
il faut pourtant restaurer la confiance
et éviter à tout prix et le retour en
force du tout voiture individuelle
alors comment va s'organiser la
gouvernance sanitaire des transports
publics qui va prendre les décisions
y aura-t-il une doctrine nationale où
cela relèvera ti de chaque autorité
organisatrice de transport
quelles mesures sanitaires allez vous
rendre obligatoire le port des masques
ou lesquelles si oui qui lui fournira
pourquoi pas également le port des gants
et sinon quelle mise à disposition de
gel quelles modifications sur les
procédures de nettoyage et quelles
garanties pour l'usager
en audition monsieur farandou nous
expliquer qu'en respectant la règle d'un
mètre entre deux passagers certains
trains perdront jusqu'à 80% de leur taux
de remplissage
comment éviter l' asphyxie dans les
transports urbains
on parle de limiter l'affluence
poursuivre le télétravail encourager à
décaler les horaires d'entrée et de
sortie des entreprises des collèges et
des lycées sont évoqués pour lisser les
pointes et améliorer la fluidité
ce sont des pistes mais se pose
également la question de l' équilibre
économique
car comment redonner une attractivité et
surtout surtout comment conserver une
compétitivité aux transports publics
avec tous ces surcoûts je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
monsieur djebbari merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs final la sénatrice merci pour
votre question qui porte évidemment sur
un sujet important à l'aune du
déconfinement progressif un sujet sur
lequel nous travaillons évidemment de
façon intense sous l'égide du premier
ministre
avant toute chose je voudrais vous
rappeler les mesures qui sont d'ores et
déjà en oeuvre dans les transports
publics puisque nous avons édicté un
décret il ya maintenant plus d'un mois
qu'ils portent obligation aux opérateurs
de désinfecter tous les véhicules de
transport au moins une fois par jour qui
interdit la vente des billets à bord par
exemple ou encore qui équipent en
masquer certains opérateurs de transport
particulièrement exposés ces mesures ont
été adaptés en lien avec les opérateurs
les autorités organisent organisatrice
pardon évidemment les organisations
syndicales du secteur des transports
dans le contexte du déconfinement
progressiez vous l'avez dit le maître
mot sera de restaurer la confiance pour
continuer à avoir une offre du transport
adapté et que les gens qui se transporte
qui en ont ce besoin le fasse dans de
bonnes conditions
confiance évidemment des usagers des
clients des différents systèmes de
transport confiance des opérateurs est
évidemment confiance et coordination
avec les élus et sur ce dernier point
nous sommes en contact précis constant
avec eux pour construire cette doctrine
sanitaire qui sera édictée et qui
tiendra compte de l'hétérogénéité des
situations territoriales
qui fait actuellement l'objet de
discussions notamment avec les régions
et avec les départements s'agissant du
transport scolaire par exemple
s'agissant des outils de protection
sanitaire vous avez cité le masque et la
distanciation social ces mesures seront
évidemment clarifier font partie
intégrale du plomb mais nous travaillons
aussi à l'amélioration drastique des
procédures de nettoyage et de
désinfection à la régulation de l'emport
maximal de personnels et de passagers
dans les trains vous l'avez vous l'avez
cité ou encore au lissage des heures de
pointe et cela sera particulièrement
précieux dans les métropoles à très
forte densité de trafic toutes ces
mesures seront connues et annoncé par le
premier ministre et soyez assurés madame
la sénatrice que le mettons tout en
oeuvre de manière à ce que les passagers
qui ont besoin de se transporter les
fasse dans de bonnes conditions
notamment de bonnes conditions
sanitaires
merci monsieur collègues nous avons
terminé avec les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement monsieur le premier
ministre madame et messieurs les
ministres merci les prochaines questions
auront lieu le mercredi 29 avril à 15
heures
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h30 pour la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
rectificatif pour 2020 notre séance est
donc suspendu
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez pu suivre en direct et dans son
intégralité sur public sénat qui a
apporté bien sûr sur le coronavirus sur
des sujets variés vous l'avez entendu de
la situation des banlieues à l'aide
sociale à l'enfance en passant par le
monde de la culture avec des questions
notamment et bien aussi sûr je le disais
les banlieues sûr aussi le budget
rectificatif je suis avec bruno
retailleau bruno retailleau président du
groupe
elle erre ici au sénat justement on va
parler ensemble et bien sûr de la
situation actuelle du coronavirus il ya
une baisse mais ils ne baissent pas très
franche du nombre de cas malgré le
confinement qui restent strictes qu'est
ce que cela vous inspire
est-ce que cela vous inquiète pourrait
bien le 11 mai moment où devrait
commencer le déconfinement bien sûr que
ça m'inquiète puisque le confinement est
parvenu à son objectif c'est-à-dire
faire en sorte qu'on désengorge nos
hôpitaux et notamment dans nos hôpitaux
le service de réanimation mais c'est
tout le confinement si vous voulez c'est
mettre une cloche sur la société
mais ça ne règle rien au fond et je dis
depuis le départ que si on veut se
déconfit n'est progressivement le 11 mai
il faut avoir une stratégie beaucoup
plus offensive
il faut suivre ce qui marche dans le nom
dans les pays en asie dans les pays en
europe
c'est à dire le dépistage massif et
c'est à dire une protection généralisée
avec le masque
justement si bête ndiaye ce midi parlé
tout à l'heure de chad que la france
voulait porter sa stratégie à 500 mille
tests par semaine pour les personnes
avec symptômes
est ce que c'est pour vous et bien une
bonne stratégie pour l'instant le
gouvernement pour les masques pour les
tests nous annoncer les chiffres et les
chiffres n'étaient pas ceux qui ont été
réalisés dans la réalité ce que je
constate aujourd'hui c'est que dans le
monde la france est au 4e rang dont la
mortalité quatrième rang voilà et
malheureusement ce que je constate aussi
c'est que dans un palmarès international
pour le nombre de tests par million
d'habitants
nous sommes vous vous tenez bien au 63e
rang
63e rang donc on a un vrai problème et
je pense qu'il faut encore une fois
entrée dans une stratégie offensive
c'est à dire tester testé massivement
ensuite tracé lorsque vous avez des
contacts qui peuvent que vous pouvez
éventuellement avoir contaminé est isolé
tous ceux qui sont contaminés
on a renvoyés chez eux par exemple de
l'hôpital des malades qui ont contaminé
leurs familles il faut casser cette
chaîne de la contamination qui est une
chaîne aujourd'hui intrafamiliales
sinon on freine l'épidémie mais on ne
leur est pas donc inspirons nous des
exemples allemands des exemples de
taiwan de l'accord est de l'autriche où
d'ailleurs bruno retailleau votre
réaction à cette étude américaine dont a
parlé d'ailleurs olivier ferrand tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle une étude
américaine qui invite à beaucoup de
prudence sur l' usage de l'hydro si
chloroquine le et bien médicaments ne
tombe on parle bien sûr le professeur
didier rahout le problème de toutes ses
études c'est que pour qu'ils puissent
vouloir dire quelque chose sur le
protocole rawood
il faut le respecter et c'est quoi le
protocole rome ces deux choses c'est un
associé la molécule de chloroquine à une
molécule d'antibiotiques premier point
et deuxième point c'est de donner aux
malades en première phase et non pas
dans une phase plus désespérés deuxième
phase grave ça ne marche pas donc voila
moi je vois qu'en france y compris on a
lancé des études qui y ont tout fait
pour biaiser le résultat soit qu'elles
n'associez que la molécule chloroquine
sans avoir la molécule d'antibiotiques
soit que est donné ce traitement
uniquement dans une deuxième phase moi
ce que je constate c'est que jadis
qualifié les travaux du professeur
certaines études je pense que oui bien
sûr et je pense que aujourd'hui on meurt
quatre fois moins à marseille alors est
ce que c'est parce que marseille il ya
une météo l'orgie spécial mais ça c'est
un chiffre voilà quand ce professeur
raoul publie des analyses sur 1000
patients on devrait vouloir s'en
inspirer finalement il ya deux écoles il
ya des gens qui disent ballets sont
prescrire les médecins
ce que on est en situation de guerre on
a une crise et c'est l'empirisme qui
commandent pido qui disent ah non non
c'est d'abord la recherche médicale avec
des règles très méthodologique qu'il
faut respecter
voilà je pense que quand on n'a pas
d'autre traitement qui fonctionne quand
on a une molécule qu'on connaît depuis
longtemps à condition que ce soit des
médecins qui la prescrivent je pense que
on doit faire un certain nombre
d'avancées dans le domaine et là aussi
je pense qu'on va rentrer trop de retard
bruno retailleau également tout à
l'heure à christophe castaner a répondu
à une question sur ces violences dans
les quartiers sensibles qui sont sous
tension on observe une hausse des
violences urbaines
le ministre de l'intérieur a bien dit
qu'il n'y avait pas moins de contrôles
là bas qu'ailleurs il a aussi dit un
message de fermeté est ce que cela vous
satisfait par rapport à la situation
actuelle des banlieues non mais les
messages c'est bien mais je crois que
les français sont lassés des paroles ils
sont laissés des mots ils savent
parfaitement contre les messages les
annonces les paroles ben voilà il ya une
énorme distances avec les actes mots ce
que je demande c'est que lorsqu'il ya
des troubles dans des quartiers dans des
villes y est systématiquement un
couvre-feu pourquoi parce que quand il
ya un couvre-feu peut-être que ça
supprime pas les violences mais ça aide
les forces de l'ordre notamment les
policiers parce que quand quelqu'un est
dehors quand il ya un couvre-feu
vous n'avez pas besoin qu'ils vous
disent par exemple qui va voir sa grand
mère non il n'a pas être dehors
voilà même si il peux vous montrer si
j'ose dire sa pièce à conviction donc je
pense qu'il faut être très ferme et il
faut prendre les moyens de cette fermeté
une toute dernière question bruno
retailleau vous l'avait dit ce matin
vous êtes favorable à travailler 37
heures par semaine pendant un an pendant
cette période qui va suivre la crise
vous assumez de demander ses efforts aux
français alors que la situation était
difficile pour certains d'entre eux est
ce que c'est vraiment le moment pour le
but bien sûr que la situation est
difficile mais justement parce que nous
avons mal préparé le déconfinement de la
france va être un des derniers pays à
ceux des confiné qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que d'autres pays
d'autres entreprises
vont capter des marchés que avait
auparavant nos entreprises ça veut dire
que ce confinement cette crise va
accélérer le décrochage français moi je
dis aux français je le retiens langage
de vérité je dis je ne connais pas dans
une expérience personnelle dans une
expérience collective de situation dont
on se sorte d'épreuve graves dont on se
sortent sans un surcroît d'efforts et
les français vont avoir le choix soit le
relèvement soit l'affaissement
je pense que si on veut demain une
meilleure prospérité bien je pense que
si on veut plus de croissance y compris
pour nos jeunes demain il va falloir se
retrousser les manches a sert à rien de
mentir aux français ils le savent à des
efforts merci beaucoup bruno retailleau
d'avoir répondu à mes questions et je
vais accueillir le président du groupe
la république en marche
ici au sénat françois patriat bonjour
bonjour françois patriat est ce que vous
êtes favorable 1 déconfinement région
par région comme le souhaite par exemple
renaud muselier ou encore hervé morin
qui font valoir que toutes les régions
françaises ne sont pas touchées de la
même manière je m'entends bien ce que
disent ces deux présidents de région de
normandie et de paca si c'est pour créer
de la polémique avec le gouvernement je
trouve que c'est pas justifiée par
contre ils reprennent aujourd'hui ce
qu'a dit l'académie de médecine il ya
presque un mois
l'académie de métier a dit qu'elle est
presque à moins qu effectivement encore
fonctions en fonction du taux de
morbidité en fonction du taux de
d'affection de chaque territoire on
pouvait en douter je crois que c'est une
des pistes qui étudie aujourd'hui le
gouvernement et pour le plan des pros
finement bon demain il est certain que
dans les régions dans département comme
dans les landes qui sont à l'opposé de
mulhouse aujourd'hui où il ya peu où il
ya peu de cas où le sait où le virus
circule peu mais je te j'entends bien
par là que les mesures qu'elle est
mesures de prévention de vente retrait
les mêmes partout parce qu'attention
imaginer que quelqu'un qui vient d'une
zone confinée et qu'il va dans une zone
d confiné où on peut circuler librement
le risque sera le même dans tous ça doit
se faire avec beaucoup de précaution
est-ce qu'il faut pouvoir rouvrir par
exemple bien les cafés et les
restaurants dans ces zones un petit peu
plus tôt c'est commerce qui souffre
tellement pour vous est-ce que d'ouvrir
un restaurant dans lequel il y aura une
distance de 20 m de mettre une personne
par table est ce que c'est
économiquement viable et rentable
est-ce que c'est viable et rentable pour
7 8 ou 10 clients ce que j'ai entendu
parler de petit village en normandie
est-ce que s'ils rentrent en vue
d'ouvrir de payer quelqu'un de repayer
des charges les frais étaient dira pour
le faire je ne suis pas convaincu la
doctrine je pense pour les restaurants
est pour l'heure restée la même
nationale mais je demande surtout pour
elle qu'il y ait un plan spécifique qui
leur permettent de passer la crise
justement à la baisse de l'activité
économique inquiète
muriel pénicaud la ministre du travail
faisait part ce matin du fait que la
barre des 10 millions de français au
chômage partiel a été franchie c'est
trop pour vous est-ce qu'il faut que le
travail reprenne reprennent au plus vite
dans ce contexte et comment d'abord je
souhaite que tous les entreprises sont
en capacité de reprendre soit parce
qu'elles ont des marchés qu'elles
peuvent reprendre les vêtements des
chantiers qui peuvent ouvrir soit et en
même temps si elles peuvent assurer la
protection de leurs salariés
tel que le prévoit le code qui a été
signé par les chefs d'entreprise ont
aujourd'hui et tel que le demande des
salariés
il est souhaitable que le maximum
d'entreprises puissent reprendre
il ya beaucoup d'artisans chez moi qui
ont repris maintenant sur le chômage
partiel 60 millions de personnes en
europe
six entreprises sur dix en france il
faut région recours aujourd'hui plus de
10 millions c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup
ça ne peut pas durer très longtemps
c'est pour ça que l'activité reprenne au
mieux et au plus vite mais en même temps
je vous rappelle que cette mesure a été
celle qui a permis à l'allemagne en
2008-2009 d'éviter qu'ils aient des
licenciements nombreux et les faillites
par ailleurs ce qui a permis la reprise
de l'activité
donc je suis favorable à cette mesure
c'est une information du site les jours
le groupe vive indiqué apport filiale
canal+ et qui vient cette filiale
utilise justement le chômage partiel
veut pour néanmoins augmenté ses
dividendes augmentation de 20% est ce
que c'est pour vous acceptable
on a en mémoire bien sûr et bien les
mots un du ministre de l'économie sur ce
sujet non mais l'ambitieux totalement
aujourd'hui opposés à ce que des
entreprises qui ont versé des dividendes
à des actionnaires
si vraiment beaucoup d'activités y
compris dans le médico social privé
aujourd'hui qui versent des dividendes
que de même temps demandé l'aide de
l'état peuvent pas à la fois avoir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre en
l'occurrence soit on suspend
momentanément les versements des
dividendes et on a les aides de l'état
sont le fait pas et on les a pas une
dernière question bruno retailleau
proposé ce matin et bien la semaine de
37 heures pendant un an pendant la
période de sortie de crise travailler
plus plus d'efforts pour sortir de la
crise est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
une bonne solution
généraliser une mesure à 37 heures ne
paraît pas bonne par contre rappeler aux
français que nous ne relevons super
identité nationale que par le travail et
parce que chacun y mettra sa quote-part
y participera je pense qu'il faut pas
penser du détenu déconfinement aux
vacances il faut penser du dépôt
finement à la façon de redresser ce pays
une mesure unilatérale ça doit pas si si
les gens doivent travailler plus est
s'ils veulent travailler plus demain
devrait y avoir des contreparties soit
en termes de défiscalisation sur en
terme d'heures supplémentaires mieux
payés soit en termes de primes mais pas
de façon unitaire comme cela toute
dernière question françois patriat est
ce que pour vous il va falloir dans le
décompte finement limiter les
déplacements entre les
région c'est que c'est parmi les pistes
du gouvernement j'ai répondu à votre
première question dans ce sens là
aujourd'hui
s'ils ont des consignes demain il faudra
je pense laisser les gens se déplace
uniquement pour des raisons de travail
pour des raisons qui sont n'est pas
limité les déplacements de confort faut
pas pourquoi demain on serait des
confiné pour aller voir telle ou telle
personne de sa famille dans tout l'hôtel
région en fin de compte on irait pour
aller en vacances et pourrait dans un
lieu plus agréable ça je pense est à
déconseiller
là encore c'est à l'appréciation de
chacun et la doctrine doit être défini
eh bien merci beaucoup françois patriat
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
nous allons continuer les matériaux mais
je vous propose de revenir à un temps
fort de la séance de questions
d'actualité
tout à l'heure la réponse notamment du
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand il
a défendu l'action des agences
régionales de santé qui sont beaucoup
critiqué 1
actuellement il m'a pour un nombre de
lourdeurs administratives
justement est bien pour olivier verront
elles se sont très très utiles dans
cette crise écoutez je voudrais qu'on
retienne que notre pays a réalisé six
cent quarante quatre évacuations
sanitaires par train par avion par
hélicoptère nous sommes le seul pays au
monde à l'avoir fait c'est une fierté
française
j'étais en lien hier avec des
réanimateurs de l'hôpital de strasbourg
qui me racontait ce que savait
représenté comme chantier monumental
pour permettre de sauver des vies c'est
un motif de fierté et nous n'aurions pas
pu le faire sans interventions
permanentes des agences régionales de
santé et de ses agents j'ajoute qu'un
certain nombre d'entre eux ont payé un
lourd tribut il ya eu des morts dans les
ars
monsieur le sénateur et des gens qui ont
continué de travailler alors qu'ils
étaient malades parce que sans les
agences régionales de santé sans leurs
agents dans les territoires tout est
perfectible
tout système surtout administratif est
perfectible et je pourrais écrire un
roman sur les difficultés les longueurs
les problèmes logistiques administratifs
que connaît notre pays comme d'autres
mais encore une fois de rendre hommage
au grand talent on ajouté et enfin sur
les dentistes je leur ai écrit hier ils
devront cent cinquante mille masques
ffp2 supplémentaire mais je crois que
notre question pour les remercier pour
s'être organisés pour assurer les
urgences sur tout le territoire depuis
plusieurs semaines mais riche pour les
semaines à venir
voilà en tout à l'heure pour cette
intervention d'olivier verrons je suis
avec claude malhuret
le président du groupe les indépendants
au sénat votre réaction d'abord et bien
à cette réponse cette défense d'olivier
véran des agences régionales de santé
qui ont été beaucoup critiqués pour leur
lourdeur administrative ces dernières
semaines le ministre de lisa sion de la
santé les a défendues je vois mal le
minier de la santé ne pas défendre des
agences régionales de santé donc il est
drôle
je crois qu'en da on a un système
centralisé en france on a les avantages
de ce système centralisé et souvent en
cas de crise généralisée c'est quand
même c'est quand même un avantage
et puis on a aussi les inconvénients
c'est une certaine bureaucratie sté
d'une certaine lourdeur c'est parfois
des retards et par conséquent retard
dans la réaction au début notamment de
oui je suis pas sûr que le syli a eu
retard au début ce soit le ce soit le
les ars qui soit qu'ils soient en charge
je crois en plus qu'il faut pas m
comment dire pas faire une
généralisation
moi je suis dans une région où je n'ai
absolument pas me plaindre de l'action
des ars en plus il ya une action drs
coordonnées obligatoirement avec les
régions avec les départements avec des
vieux c'est un rôle qui n'est pas facile
alors j'imagine puisque j'entends des
critiques qu'il y à des endroits et les
ars sont souvent dans les jeux par les
directeurs des ars sont souvent des gens
avec des personnalités différentes et la
personnalité du directeur
on pourrait penser que ça soit
directement par exemple mais c'est comme
les préfets vous avez préféré ou aussi
des personnalités et puis le préfet de
la région parisienne par exemple fait
également office de paris a une
personnalité que tout le monde a vu à la
télévision qui est particulier donc
voilà il ya des cas d'espèce et bien
entendu dans un telle crise
il peut y avoir j'imagine des critiques
j'entends des critiques que de mal hurel
déconfinement devrait donc commencer le
11 mai on a pour l'instant on peut être
plus de questions que de réponses par
rapport à cette période
est ce que pour vous vous estimez que
c'est le bon horizons pour entamer ce
déconfinement je suis d'accord avec vous
il est évident aujourd'hui qu'on a
beaucoup plus de questions que de
réponses
et tout le monde a beaucoup plus de
questions que de réponses et tous les
pays ont beaucoup plus de questions que
de réponses et les gouvernements étant
aujourd'hui à la face des
questionnements et dans la préparation
des réponses
j'espère puisque le premier ministre
doit d'ici la fin avril début mai
proposé les mesures de déconfinement qui
donneront l'objet qui sont l'objet d'un
débat au parlement
j'espère qu'à ce moment là nous aurons
plus de réponses que de questions mais
il est évident aujourd'hui je parle même
avant déconfinement de la préparation du
tracking la préparation des écoles et
des systèmes scolaires etc
il est évident qu'il ya aujourd'hui plus
de cas sont violents et encore toujours
plus de questions médicales et
virologiques et épidémiologiques sur le
virus lui même
donc tout le monde a aujourd'hui plus de
questions que de réponses on évolue avec
la crise on a peut-être le plus
d'informations c'est pour l'instant
l'école le
déconfinement sur trois semaines pour
les enfants avec ce système de rotation
peut être pour avoir rôdé 2000 groupe ça
vous paraît tenable je crois que ça va
être difficile il va falloir une
vraiment une conjonction entre l'état
les airs 20 ans tant locaux du ministère
de l'éducation nationale
les maires bien entendu et les
départements et les régions puisque les
systèmes scolaires fait participer
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales
c'est une première mais il va y avoir
sans doute des frottements j'espère que
ça va se passer
le mieux possible et puis il va y avoir
bien entendu le cas des enseignants qui
peuvent si les enfants ne font pas des
formes graves les enseignants eux non
pas cinq ans ou dix ans et ils peuvent
être visités et donc il va falloir
prendre une toute dernière question sur
le parlement dans cette période de
confinement des voix s'élèvent jusque le
parlement peut faire seulement un
contrôle canada dry jeu reprend les mots
de marie pierre de la gontrie sur ce
sujet est-ce que vous jugez lui aussi
bien qu'il n'a pas la place qu'il
devrait dans ce contexte je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde sait tout
le monde toutes les administrations
toutes les entreprises font du canada
dry
est-ce que vous avez vu une entreprise
qui fonctionne à 100% est-ce que vous
avez une administration qui fonctionne à
100 sauf celle de la santé qui elle
fonctionne à 150 % mais à part ça c'est
le cas de tout le monde donc le
parlement il était dans la crise comme
l'ensemble du pays cela dit faut quand
même relativiser regarder cet après midi
nous sommes en train de voter le projet
de loi de finances rectificative
nous allons voter le plan de confinement
il y à quelques temps nous avons voté la
loi d'urgence sanitaire et nous sommes
comme chaque semaine pour les questions
au gouvernement ou là où le gouvernement
doit répondre au contrôle du sénat est
fière de l'assemblée nationale donc bien
entendu peut-être on peut veut on peut
dire c'est du canada dry mais le
parlement ne n'a abandonné ni sa
fonction même si nous sommes moins
nombreux en séance bien entendu mais en
a abandonné ni notre fonction de
juste la theurre ni notre fonction de
contrôle eh bien merci beaucoup claude
malhuret d'avoir répondu à mes questions
je vais à présent accueillir vincent
eblé
le président socialiste de la commission
des finances vous parliez justement du
budget rectificatif ce budget il est en
cours d'examen ici aussi n'a encore
certainement aujourd'hui ce soir bien
sûr
est-il pour vous à la hauteur des enjeux
110 milliards d'euros fait valoir le
gouvernement c'est plus que deux fois
plus que le premier plan qui était prévu
et qui avait été voté par le sénat
quelques jours après le début du
confinement
oui en effet s'il s'agit de faire une
comptabilité de ce plfr 2 en comparaison
du premier plfr qui nous a été proposé
il y a quelques semaines
il est en effet plus important et nous
l'avons bien volontiers acte et ma
nation quand oui sans doute je les dis
comme ça en tout cas en séance mais
quand à considérer que cela serait
suffisant ce n'est pas tout à fait la
position
de mon groupe est la mienne nous
considérons que il serait possible
d'aller encore plus loin dans certains
domaines par exemple dans la prise en
charge
j'irai de la travers cette crise par les
françaises et les français les plus
fragiles
c'est la question par exemple d'un
soutien aux étudiants d'un soutien aux
victimes du coc vide à malte et magna
macro avait parlé en ce soutien aux
étudiants précaires mais lui on n'a pas
la traduction bien sûr alors assez
souvent d'ailleurs nos amendements ne
font que reprendre des idées qui ont été
évoqués dans le débat public et parfois
même par les membres du gouvernement ou
des membres de la majorité
gouvernementale mais on n'en voit pas la
traduction de lessay g un petit problème
et puis il ya inversion qui n'est un
versant qui n'est pas du tout traités
c'est le versant des ressources
donc c'est très bien de financer par le
déficit on n'y est pas forcément hostile
on va pas avoir les yeux rivés sur les
équilibres budgétaires que la france a
objectivement perdu depuis au moins 40
ans mais enfin on en arrive à une
situation où il serait peut-être
possible de faire contribuer aux charges
de cette crise en tout cas les segments
économiques qui iraient ne se porte pas
mal du fait de la crise la raison le
second tour évidemment le secteur des
assurances c'est un vrai sujet donc nous
l'avons proposé et d'autres groupes
politiques que le mien l'ont proposé
dans l'hémicycle et il ya eu une
convergence des analyses et nous avons
pu dégoter un amendement en ce sens
quand j'irai le gouvernement nous
présente à la fin de la première partie
un amendement pour un article déquilibre
qui ajuste les montants financiers du
projet de loi de finances rectificative
de ce qui a été voté il met 0 en phase
de cette proposition donc c'est voté par
le parlement
il faut bien que le gouvernement tienne
compte mais il ne veut pas traduire la
réalité financière de ce vote je trouve
ça particulièrement désobligeants à
l'égard de la représentation nationale
je le dis en tant que tel vous portez
votre groupe porte également des
amendements pour le rétablissement de
liesse f que répondez vous à ceux qui
vous disent pas ce combat là et bien
c'est celui d'hier ce n'est pas celui
d'aujourd'hui sont les mots par exemple
d'hervé marseille qui estime que je
réponds qu hervé marseille n'a pas lu
l'amendement que nous allons proposer
car nous ne proposons pas leur
rétablissement de liesse f d'autrefois
nous proposons une nouvelle formule
d'imposition sur le capital qui par
exemple tient compte du fait que analyse
que j'ai conduite avec le rapporteur
général du budget nous avons un nid sf
autrefois qui permettait à certains
traits aux contribuables très fort
patrimoine d'échappée totalement à cette
imposition parce que il suffit de m
vos ressources j'irai à zéro et de
capitaliser joguin du fait de votre très
grandes fortunes et d'emprunter par
exemple pour couvrir vos charges
courantes de la vie courante et vous
êtes protégé et vous ne payez plus
l'impôt sur la fortune
donc il ya de très grands noms que je ne
donnerai pas ici de très grandes
fortunes françaises mais qui sont bien
connus j'irai les français et des
spécialistes et pas que de spécialistes
qui j'irai utilisées ainsi ce dispositif
donc lisf 2.0 que je propose c'est un
nid à celle de nouvelle génération qui
fait véritablement payer les très riches
et pour ne pas alourdir l'impôt sur la
fortune tel qu'il existait j'irai encore
récemment nous proposons d'alléger des
plus petits riches qui eux ne seraient
plus taxes et donc j'y reste c'est une
réforme complète de la fiscalité sur le
capital
vincent eblé c'est une information du
site les jours votre réaction au fait
que vive indiqué bénéficie du chômage
partiel notamment pour sa filiale canal+
aux commandes c'est dividendes pour
est-ce que pour vous c'est une situation
acceptable
oui j'ai cru comprendre qu'il s'agissait
d'une augmentation de 20 pour cent pour
cent c'est tout à fait scandaleux c'est
extrêmement choquant et d'ailleurs
chacun on avait convenu puisque ils
avaient été demandés y compris j'irai
par des membres du gouvernement que
j'irai les entreprises qui bénéficient
des aides de l'état et en particulier
pour le dispositif du chômage partiel ne
distribuent pas de dividendes à leurs
actionnaires et on voit que malgré cette
affirmation qui presque là pour amuser
la galerie semble-t-il fierais aucun
dispositif véritablement contraignant
n'est adoptée en la matière donc en
effet c'est extrêmement choquant et nous
dénonçons tout à fait c'est pratique et
nous demandons que des dispositions
opérante soient mises en oeuvre pour les
interdire eh bien merci à beaucoup
vincent eblé d'avoir répondu à mes
questions va poursuivre les interviews
mais tout de suite
retour à un autre temps fort de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et notamment et bien la
réponse de christophe castaner le
ministre de l'intérieur
qui a été interrogé et bien sûr ces
violences qu'il y a dans certains
quartiers sensibles en france ces
derniers jours écouté le ministre de
l'intérieur est vrai que dans ces
quartiers au moment où nous intervenons
il peut arriver qu'il y ait des
provocations qu'il y ait des atteintes à
nos forces sécurité des mises en cause
de l'utilisation de différents
projectiles contre nos forces de
sécurité ces dernières nuits vous l'avez
rappelé en particulier depuis samedi
soir des guets-apens ont été organisées
et là encore je vais vous dire que
d'abord nous les condamnons de la façon
la plus ferme et nous réagissons
immédiatement la nuit dernière une
quinzaine de faits se sont déroulés sur
le territoire national douze personnes
ont été interpellées depuis le week-end
dernier ce sont 28 qui ont été
interpellés le seul sénateur mesdames et
sénateurs n'ayant aucun doute nous
veillons à faire en sorte que le
confinement soit respectée partout en
france et partout nos forces de sécurité
intérieures sont mises en cause sont
provoquées nous leur devons protection
nous le faisons et nous devons
sanctionné cela de la façon la plus
ferme possible et je suis avec alain
joyandet sénateurs les républicains de
la haute saône c'est vous qui interrogé
justement le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner sur ces violences
qu'il ya dans certains quartiers
sensibles parce que vous avez des
satisfait par la réponse du ministre qui
dit notamment et bien qu'il n'y a pas
moins de contrôle dans ce quartier
sensible qu'ailleurs kangoo qu'il n'y a
pas de laxisme en tout cas de la part
des forces de l'ordre
je crois surtout que cette crise révèle
nos faiblesses et faiblesses que nous
avons eues collectivement ferment un peu
les yeux sur ce qui se passait dans ces
banlieues et on voit bien que même en
temps de decaux vide 19 sur la question
du confinement est bien le confinement
n'est pas respectée dans ces endroits de
la république la république se perd un
peu donc christophe castaner me dise
effectivement il ya des il ya des
contrôles il ya des patrouilles mais on
voit bien quand même que les policiers
sont attaqués des voitures de sos
médecins sont attaqués un récidiviste
qui a été condamné 14 fois rentrer dans
un car de police
mais c'est presque la police qui est
mise au banc des accusés
donc je pense qu'il ya un moment donné
il faut
reprendre une véritable action de
sécurité sur ces territoires de la
république parce qu'autrement on va
repartir dans des émeutes comme en 2005
parce qu'effectivement le problème du
confinement pose d'autres problèmes à
ceux qui sont les animateurs de ces
quartiers
cela montre aussi l'ampleur de la crise
sociale des difficultés aussi dans
certains quartiers sensibles là le
problème est peut être aussi là alain
joyandet
la crise sociale n'est pas le
déclencheur de ce qui se passe en ce
moment parce que sous le manteau on
parle d'autre chose sous le manteau on
parle de drogue on parle de choses comme
ça
on parle de deux deals qui ne sont plus
organisables en période de confinement
c'est pour ça aussi que le confinement
n'est pas respectée ça ne date pas
évidemment de d'hier c'est-à-dire un
certain nombre d'années mais en ce
moment c'est à nouveau en train de
ressurgir parce que les bandes évident
qu'ils ne peuvent pas organiser leurs
petites affaires sont actuellement en
pleine turbulence et donc je pense qu'il
faudrait sans doute que les forces de
l'ordre mettent un peu le paquet comme
on dit des fermes étaient un peu plus de
fermeté je pense sans doute un peu plus
de moyens pour que on n'est pas une
crise sécuritaire qui s'ajoute à la
crise sanitaire c'est déjà suffisamment
difficile pour le gouvernement vous
noterez d'ailleurs que pour la crise
sanitaire l'opposition fait bloc avec le
gouvernement nous sommes comme très
constructif et c'est pour ça que je
pensais qu'il était il était bon
d'alerter le gouvernement sur le fait
que pendant cette crise sanitaire il
faut surtout pas laisser dériver ce qui
se passe en ce moment les médias n'en
parlent pas trop parce que l'actualité
c'est vraiment le virus mais il faut
être très très attentif à ce qui est en
train de se passer en ce moment
autrement ça pourrait exploser
on entend tout de même des critiques
dans votre camp notamment sur le plan de
déconfinement du gouvernement que l'on
ne connaît pas encore on connaît surtout
la date le 11 mai et puis l'essentiel de
ce que l'on connaît ce plan et c'est
finalement ce qui concerne les écoles
est ce que pour vous ce timing vous
paraît aujourd'hui satisfaisant est ce
que vous jugez que et bien on est sur
les rails pour un début d confinement le
11 mai vous savez si c'était facile on
le saurait donc c'est facile pour
personne pour aucun gouvernement pour
aucun président moi j'ai été très sévère
avec le gouvernement et le président
dans le début de la gestion de la crise
je trouve que là les choses sont en
train d'être
en inde une manière un petit peu
différente le président je pense à titre
personnel ça n'engage que moi a bien
fait de donner une date
mais d'ici cette date évidemment c'est
pas anormal qu'il y ait un peu de
balbutiement pour savoir comment tout ça
va se va s'organiser qui est des
craintes c'est normal qu'ils aient des
peurs c'est normal qu'ils aient des
doutes c'est normal aussi mais je suis
tenté de dire qu'il faut maintenant
sortir l'allemagne en sort l'autriche en
sort les anglais en sortent donc il faut
pas non plus a ajouté une crise
économique dont on va pas sortir on va
pas faire déposer le bilan à la france
non plus donc il faut changer de
stratégie à mon avis il faut sortir du
du confinement mais avec toutes les
barrières sanitaires possibles sert que
pour l'instant on n'a pas les barrières
sanitaires c'est ça qui fait peur on
parle du 11 mai on n'a pas les barrières
sanitaires faut les masques il faut les
goûts les protections faux
l'organisation il faut la logistique il
faut tout ça mais le président a bien
fait de fixer une date
et d'ici cette date il faut absolument
qu'on soit organisé mais il faut en
sortir parce qu'il faut que la france
s'en sorte
il faut que les gens puissent repartir
au boulot et bien merci à beaucoup alain
joyandet a répondu à mes questions et je
vais également accueillir à présent
fabien gay sénateur communiste de la
seine saint denis merci beaucoup alain
joyandet
fabien gay une première question sur la
situation et bien des banlieues il ya eu
une question tout à l'heure notamment à
christophe castaner la tension est
montée d'un cran notamment en banlieue
parisienne on parle des hauts-de-seine
on parle aussi de la seine saint denis
est ce que pour reprendre les mots
d'olivier klein le maire de
clichy-sous-bois vous jugez que cela
peut déraper à tout moment non mais je
m'inscris en faux y compris avec les
propos de mon collègue précédent
monsieur joyandet
il n'y a pas un non respect du
confinement dans les banlieues
populaires ça fait maintenant un mois
que qu'une grande partie de la droite
répète ça absolument ça n'a pas été le
cas notamment seine-saint-denis nommé
même le préfet les élus locaux nous
avons des problèmes
personne ne nie ça nous avons des
questions sociales
d'abord économique aussi sécuritaire
évidemment personne ne nie ça mais le
confinement il est autant respecté
qu'ailleurs les hommes et les femmes en
banlieue se confine parce qu'eux aussi
ont peur de la crise sanitaire
oui celle montée des tensions oui c'est
plus dur
c'est plus dur d'être confiné dans un
hlm et parfois dans un hlm dans un type
de logement dégradé très précarisés en
plus vous ajoutez une précarité rampante
il ya une question autour de l'aide
alimentaire maintenant qu'ils se posent
notamment en seine-saint-denis
les associations sont à bout de souffle
nous le disent on pourra voir une crise
alimentaire très rapidement donc il faut
il faut que les fonds il faut débloquer
il faut aider sein d'associations et
puis l'état de reprendre pour prendre en
charge ces questions là mais arrêtons de
répéter ça sans cesse cette
stigmatisation des quartiers populaires
des boucles de la seine saint denis est
insupportable aînés autant respecté
qu'ailleurs et je rappelle d'ailleurs
que beaucoup d'habitants des quartiers
populaires sont au travail aujourd'hui
ce qu'on appelle les invisibles prennent
le rer b tous les jours ils vont au
travail ce sont les aides soignantes ce
sont les éboueurs ce sont les caissières
les caissiers et ils sont en première
ligne
donc arrêtons avec tout ça j'en ai marre
moins d'enchaîner les plateaux de
télévision pour arrêter ça et je ne suis
pas un pleureur nous sommes extrêmement
offensif nous demandons l'égalité
républicaine depuis des années dans dans
notre département plus de moyens aux lys
prise de moyens de justice plus de
moyens d'éducation c'est ça que nous
avons besoin notamment au moment de la
crise mais aussi tout au long de l'année
fabien guerre actuellement le sénat est
également en train de débattre du budget
rectificatif 1 le deuxième but du
rectificatif depuis le début de la crise
ou présentez-vous est notamment
favorable à une taxe
amazon sur cale motifs et cela malgré la
fermeture des entrepôts en france ces
derniers jours
oui la question c'est qui va payer la
crise donc la droite le medef et le
gouvernement et ils ont résolu le
problème ça fait dix jours que nous
explique que ce sont les salariés qui
vont devoir payer la crise moins de
congés allonger le temps de travail pas
forcément payer les heures
supplémentaires enfin chacun bas dans la
surenchère où il ya la question oui il
va falloir faire contribuer notamment
les plus riches qui sont exemptés de
beaucoup de choses depuis le début de ce
quinquennat pour pour abonder notamment
ce fonds d'urgence
donc la question le e-commerce
fonctionne alors que nos commerces ont
été fermés
il n'est pas anormal de dire que on va
les taxer pour abonder ce fonds
d'urgence notamment pour les commerces
qui sont fermés et notamment aussi avec
un retour de l'impôt sur la fortune
le groupe socialiste a lui aussi apporté
des amendements dans ce sens en faisant
valoir et bien un nouvel impôt sur la
fortune
mais oui lisf bien sûr on va nous dire
c'est un symbole c'est 3,8 milliards ça
ne suffira pas seul mais c'est
l'ensemble petite baisse de ça rapporte
rien mais c'est l'ensemble de ces
dispositions c'est un signal envoyé les
sf le refus du gouvernement et la droite
sénatoriale aux plantes et les 1% des
revenus un peu d'imposition refuse à
revenir sur la flat tax pour refuser
mais par contre ils nous disent vous
inquiétez pas tout le monde va nous voir
retrouve sécher ses manches ne tombe
notamment les salariés c'est-à-dire déjà
les plus précarisés les 9 millions et
demi de personnes qui sont au chômage
partiel qui soit 84 % de leurs de leurs
salaires aujourd'hui est ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir contribuer non donc les 1% les
plus riches il faut qu'ils contribuent
donc commençons par l' isf
et puis par d'autres mesures notamment
une taxe sur les dividendes par exemple
voyez certains pays font le choix de ne
pas verser de dividende
c'est une question qui est posée mais
ici le gouvernement et la droite
sénatoriale et le medef s'en réjouit on
refuse tous les tous nos arguments mais
on va continuer et de toute façon le
débat va continuer dans le pays parce
que le plus grand nombre commença à
venir sur toutes ces questions de
justice fiscale sociale et
environnementale et bien gagné d'avoir
répondu à mes questions et tu tombes a
également écouté et bien une interview
d'albe eric de montgolfier le rapporteur
général du budget qui actuellement est
en train et bien alors alors
qu'actuellement le sénat est en train de
débattre du budget rectificatif le
deuxième depuis le début de la crise
senna a des propositions d'évolution de
loi qui vise à créer un régime
d'assurance contre la pandémie donc un
peu comme les catastrophes naturelles
sasa programme pour l'avenir pour le
pour le présent on souhaite que le
secteur de l'assurance contribuent plus
qu'ils ne contribuent actuellement il ya
six mois un accident actuellement en
occident on vous l'avait dit il n'y a
pas de circulation routière par exemple
n'a sans doute moins de cambriolages
dont cassant nombre de sinistres qui
sont en baisse et s'est passablement
l'aléa habituel c'est qu'on existait sur
très particulière lorsque vous êtes
comme aujourd'hui interdits brand
reculer par définition on est sur une
page où le contrat devrait presque être
suspendue donc nous souhaitons et nous
avons voté des dispositions qui apporte
une contribution financière de
l'assurance à la créo hautement avec des
recettes supplémentaires
plus globalement le sénat sur ce budget
rectificatif est plutôt dans une
position constructive mais vous voulez
aller plus loin dans le soutien aux
entreprises notamment par un mécanisme
de crédit d'impôt vous ne craignez pas
pour les finances publiques
en tout ce sont des associations
totalement folle totalement hors normes
on était à peu près 90 milliards de
déficit
lorsqu'on a voté le budget pour l'année
2020 ont le double quasiment donc en
trois mois on a explosé les chiffres
habituels donc c'est une c soit
excessivement compliqué c'était aussi
une citation il s'agit de lancer une
bouée de sauvetage pour sauver les
entreprises pour aider les particuliers
dont je pense qu'on n'est pas vraiment à
ce stade malheureusement à être dans l'
équilibre budgétaire
ce qu'il faut c'est ce que fait le sénat
veiller à ce que personne ne reste au
bord de la route échappent aux
dispositifs et donc nous sommes plutôt
dans l'amélioration des dispositifs
gouvernementaux que dans la construction
d'un nouveau projet d'un autre projet ça
viendra mais ce sera un autre temps
certains pensent qu' il ya des
entreprises qui peuvent contribuer plus
par exemple laurent berger qui
voudraient la mise en place d'une
contribution exceptionnelle pour les
entreprises non impactés
est ce que vous seriez favorable à un
tel mécanisme
déjà faudrait savoir qu'il n'est pas
affectée parce qu'aujourd'hui on va
parler de la grande distribution
elles vont peut-être des pactes et l'on
tête du riz mais il ya moins de clients
aucun aucun secteur n'était aujourd'hui
épargné par la crise
or il y en a qui sont vraiment dans une
situation dramatique un restaurant qui
est fermée qui restera fermée après le
11 mai asus de son difficile et puis en
a qui sont sans doute moins impactés
mais aucun secteur n'était épargné cette
touche tout le monde touche le commerce
mondial se touchent au commerce français
ça touche l'industrie donc c'est très
difficile de savoir jusqu'où du tarn
amazon penser que regarder même liste
difficulté distribution il n'y a pas de
la poste quelques jours par semaine donc
on voit aujourd'hui que tous les
secteurs sont impactés après la question
du financement de ces mesures de la
fiscalité des mesures de fond c'est une
question qui se posera m'aide
aujourd'hui on souhaite rester à
l'urgence et d'urgence aujourd'hui c'est
bien sûr le sanitaire comme
on sort de déconfinement et c'est aussi
sur le plan économique comment pendant
cette période très compliquée la plus
courte possible
on essaie de sauver les entreprises
après la question fiscale de la dette
tout ça ça se posera mais par mois là
bas au plus pressé c'est à dire sauvons
nos entreprises sont venues l'emploi une
dernière question vous espérez une
commission mixte paritaire conclusive
vous pensez que le projet de loi
pourrait être adopté demain vendredi
peut-être alors nous espérons le récit
d'une commission mixte paritaire puisque
l'évolution de fait le sénat sont
raisonnables je mens se vendent à
l'amélioration du dispositif je pense
qu'ils veulent être entendus par nos
collègues députés
et je pense que dans l'esprit qui est
celui d'un esprit collectif de lutte
contre cette épidémie est bien sûr de
lutte contre les problèmes économiques
considérables que nous avons je pense
que ce serait vraiment l'esprit de
réussir cette cmp tous les cas je
l'espère et je crois que le sénat va
continuer son travail cet après midi et
nous pourrons j'espère conclure
favorablement demain
voilà pour cette interview d'albe eric
de montgolfier le rapporteur général du
budget cela alors que le sénat est en
train de débattre du deuxième budget
rectificatif
depuis le début de la crise du
coronavirus les travaux parlementaires
se poursuivent sur public sénat tout de
suite on va poursuivre une audition
celle de la direction d'air france air
france klm et notamment avec son grand
patron le ben smith une audition en
visioconférence
sous la houlette de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable et cela alors que
air france est en très grande difficulté
notez que l'état français et l'état
néerlandais ont déjà dit qu'ils allaient
garantira les prêts blank bancaires de
plusieurs milliards d'euros
l'état se dit donc au rendez vous pour
venir en aide à air france tout de suite
on prend la direction de cette audition
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui dans un
contexte je vois bien qu'aucun d'entre
nous n'aurait pu imaginer
lors de notre dernière audition l'apport
des devis du common un virus très
violemment agressé l'ensemble de
l'économie
et tout particulièrement comme vous le
savez le secteur aérien dans des
proportions totalement inédite et en
provoquant l'arrêt de pratiquement tous
les vols à travers le monde
selon les estimations de l'association
internationale du transport aérien iata
les pertes pourraient atteindre 290
milliards d'euros en 2000 à 81,2
milliards pour l'europe seules
rappelons cette chronologie de quelques
semaines qui ont vu la chute de
l'activité 23 janvier fermeture de
l'aéroport de goma nancy